[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
remember
but when everything is paralyzed
now let's see
[Music]
thank you
check check check one two one two one
two one two
give me one second guys I gotta post I
forgot to post this on uh
need to make a post for YouTube saying
that we're going live there
since that is where we are indeed live
at the moment
there we go
oh oh hold on hold on I need to put an
image with it
gotta have an image with it you know how
it goes
that one
foreign
perfect little uh Square there
all right let's do this
[Music]
let's do this
ladies and Gentlemen people of the
internet
retrock and tour here just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
Welcome to our full
review
I I've known for a while I wanted to do
a full review of this game
and I'll probably end up posting a
separate video on it too but
it I almost need like a live stream like
this to
condense everything well this is not
gonna be condensed this is gonna be
lengthy we're gonna go in depth here and
then from there condense it
into a video instead
I'm going to turn down the music just a
bit hold on let's see let's put it at
minus
that is at five percent I don't know how
it's so loud whatever turned it down now
yeah I mean obviously this is a game
we've been covering for a long time and
if you're watching this on the replay I
will put time stamps in the video
description and then you could also jump
around in the timeline because I know
this is probably when people want to go
back to so if you're watching this later
I know there's a lot of people who are
still on other consoles who want to
avoid spoilers and everything so
well the part here at the beginning
we'll just kind of catch up and chat for
a little bit with everybody so you don't
have to worry about any spoilers there
and then we'll shift into the actual
review
which I was trying to outline out last
night like how do I want to go about
this because I don't want this to be
like a traditional review traditional
review it's like hey everybody liked
here's what we didn't like here's kind
of our overall thoughts and we're done
we're out
but this is a game that we have
studied
and I don't use that word lightly I mean
we have studied this game and every well
I shouldn't even say the game we've
studied every bit of information that is
been released for this game for a while
and so for a channel like ours I just
didn't feel like it would do it justice
just to do a normal review and then move
on like that's it right
so thank you guys for being here we are
in the non-spoilery portion at the
moment so let me catch up with the chat
here looks like Jake was our very first
one tonight Jake how's it going dude
welcome in welcome in Marco soundtrack
in the house Jenna is here
as well Anna Pim welcome Anna how's it
going
Anna said she's not gonna be able to
make it too long I think it's late for
you or early depending on where you are
Nico the real life Chief warlock in the
house welcome in Nico also Ken ready to
hear some hot takes
we'll see if we have any hot takes we'll
see if I don't we might have a couple
hot takes might have one or two hot
takes
Black Rose welcome in thank you for
being here nightbot hey nightbots here
on the job tonight
G8
goon maybe maybe that's supposed to be
goon just got the official game guy
looks fantastic yeah there's a lot of
good artwork even in the game guide
which I I still have not been able to
fully look through I've skimmed the art
book
I have I wouldn't even call it skim on
the game guide but I've I've glanced at
it but I really want to dive in here
when I have some more time
uh let's see Jenna Lee Turner
welcome in General Lee Turner good to
see you there
uh oh we got nearly headless Nick
somebody just got welcomed into
Gryffindor
we've got l in the real life Newt in the
house gifting out the five tier one
memberships
elwin good to see you tonight thank you
so much for dropping in
gifting those five memberships guys if
you got one of the gifteds make sure you
thank Elwyn I also saw I don't know if
it was stream elements like refreshing
or what right when we started the stream
tonight there were a bunch of people
renewing memberships so it's very
possible it could have just been
refreshing and catching up
but either way I want to say thank you
to Megan guwop
staffy politis Stefan lonkey JP L Hooves
Brittany templargaming the flash a
kashiki Gonzalez Yoda okay wait hold on
before Gonzalez all those are channel
members welcome back to house wrecking
tour thank you all for being here and
choosing to to be members here enjoy the
emotes that you get to use in chat also
a special Discord role as well and then
Gonzalez Yoda and S groninger
subscribing to the channel
elwin then gifting out those five
memberships so congrats to those of you
who got the five gifted right there
and Ellen thank you so much for your
support guys
also big big giveaway I want to make
sure I get this in at the beginning in
case anybody misses it giveaway we are
doing a giveaway for the Hogwarts Legacy
collector's edition
on the PlayStation 5. unopened
the giveaway is legit
um this is this is the version that I
bought for my or this is the copy that I
bought for myself
WB actually ended up giving us a copy of
the collector's edition which was very
very kind of them but we're not allowed
to give that one away however the one
that I paid for I can give away so I'm
giving that away to you guys the
community really to say thank you for
all the support over the past
two and a half three years I mean it's
been a crazy ride with this game so if
you are watching this replay Squad if
you're watching this before March 17th
Friday March 17th you can still get in
on the contest
so I will make sure it's not going to be
in there now but now if you post
exclamation point giveaway in the chat
so Chatters that are here live you'll be
able to see the link there
but after the stream I'm actually going
to make a note to myself right now so I
don't forget this
but after the stream if you're watching
this on replay I will pin a comment and
I'm also going to put it in the video
description
so
video description
link
or contest
so the only way you can enter is through
a website called gleam g-l-e-a-m and I
have a link that takes you specifically
to my contest giveaway page there's a
bunch of different ways you can enter if
you do all of them then you get like 10
additional entries so it's things like
log into twitch follow retro
recintuitour on Twitch check out retro
reckon Tour on YouTube those sorts of
things and so for every little task you
do you'll get an entry I think following
me on Twitter is worth three and
following me on Twitch is worth three so
those are worth a little bit more but
then if you do everything
you'll get 10 additional now if you're
somebody you're like hey retro I don't
have any of those things and I don't
want to sign up there's one on there
there's one on there that all it says is
like answer a question
and you just like you could type in I
mean try to legitimately answer it but
if you don't want to you don't have to
just put as long as you put something in
there
that'll at least be one entry for you it
does require an email because I have to
have a way to contact you and if you win
you will have to give me an actual
address it could be a business it could
be your home it could be your parents
your brother your uncle whoever you know
doesn't matter but I need a place to
ship it and I will say like I will try
to ship it to anywhere in the world I
don't mind
hold on Mrs raconteur's texting anytime
she texts me it's always
it's always if she texts me during
stream I'm like okay I should probably
look at it Chandler is in the chat yo
Chandler wood here tonight
so you missed his wrecking tour guys
she's looking out for me she's looking
out for me she's like oh no he's doing
that thing where he's behind on the it's
okay Miss Dragon tour it's okay however
thank you for letting me know Chandler
wood in the house ladies and gentlemen
Community manager
Hogwarts Legacy
Chandler put out a pretty funny clip
just the other day if you guys didn't
see this the cats I'm telling you dude
the cats in Hogwarts Legacy you guys you
thought they were innocent
nah nah see you guys know the regulars
here know the issue that I have with
cats in the real world actually I really
like cats I probably have a cat if I
wasn't highly highly allergic to them
I know Chandler Chandler has a couple
cats dude Chandler it's ridiculous man
like when I'm
I my eyes just start itching like crazy
they turn super red I start sneezing
even when I've told this story before on
stream but there was one time we were at
a friend's house she actually put her
cat away the cat wasn't even in the room
but there was like a bunch of us there
so several of us were sitting in the
floor and so I kind of had my hands like
behind me
and I don't even know if we knew she had
a cat or not maybe we did know but when
I got up like I had obviously had cat
hair from sitting on the floor must have
gotten it on my hands or something
oh it was crazy
it was crazy so yeah but if you guys
didn't see Chandler's clip on Twitter
check it out not in the official game
just some just a little Dev magic
something the devs had fun with all
right let me get caught up here let me
get caught up with the the chat here but
thank you guys so much uh for those of
you who uh renewed your membership but
yeah as far as the contest goes uh you
guys can do exclamation point giveaway
that'll give you all the details you
need for how you can actually enter
uh and yeah then the end of this week
March 17th 5 p.m that's the latest you
can sign up we'll announce a winner uh
it is the U.S copy of the game that's
the other thing I was going to say so I
mean if you're like UK Australia
somewhere else you know you can enter
and I will I'll bite the bullet I'll
ship it wherever I need to ship it but I
don't know I don't know like how the
region locking and all that works on
Playstation I have no idea so just know
that everything you're going to be
getting was was bought here in the US
it's us copy
all right now let's get caught up with
our chat here I see Ginny in the house
as well Jenny good to see you here Damia
won Professor Baxter uh JJ Styx Draco
Craig Dennison Craig good to see you
here my friend
uh Emily let's get those hot takes
zutara welcome in zutara
l or Izzy XP I was like l z z y Izzy
good to see you Izzy welcome in welcome
in
there's Chandler let's see oh it did the
thing it did the thing again guys
it's Pi Day I can't stay long heading to
pick up a couple of pizza pies for
dinner definitely be on the replay a
awesome Chandler appreciate you stopping
by man
appreciate you stopping by yeah I'm
looking forward to this one I've
I rarely do whenever we do lives I mean
it's I have like kind of a general
outline of what we're going to cover but
it's usually pretty kind of off the cuff
you know we have one or two main topics
but this one man I I was like I really
want to do
like I was saying in the beginning I
just want to do the game justice so I
really want to break it down and give
give everybody more than just our usual
the usual kind of review you'd get for a
game you know
what the Christie five months Christy
thank you so much for renewing your
membership and all that you do for our
community here Christy thanks retro for
giving us such an amazing place to come
together appreciate y'all a appreciate
you Christy then we have Brian in the
chat Michael in the chat
uh let's see little pavayo paveo I never
know how to say that one welcome in
MacGyver I don't think I've ever seen
you here before MacGyver welcome in
appreciate you stopping by oh Lord what
I love that name o l o r d oh Lord if
you could create your own spin-off
sequel what would you base it on love
your vids mate you're a legend hey thank
you so much appreciate the kind words
sequel or spin-off we've talked about
this somewhat I think it's gonna need to
be like a whole separate video at some
point
so like kind of my idea
I mean we definitely need a year six and
year seven at some point whether it's
DLC whether it's a second game I don't
know
I almost don't even want to die oh man I
I want to answer that question oh Lord I
do but I feel like then that's like a
whole other video that might be a future
live stream though we've talked about
that a little bit
but I feel like we could do a full deep
dive on that too like DLC sequel I do
have a video out
just to kind of give you something
because I feel bad not answering your
question just kind of give you something
I do have a video on things I would like
to see added to the current version of
Hogwarts Legacy so not like big DLC type
stuff but just more
uh what would you call it sort of like
quality of life updates that would
benefit everybody I know they're working
hard right now on the versions of the
game for
PS4 and Xbox One and then of course the
switch as well
and it's midnight here catch three play
a sounds good Anna appreciate your
support
Let's see we got moonlace DC oh wait
that's Moon spark how's it going Moon
Spark
Mrs raconteur even you you saw the Cat
video too oh my goodness the cats
Avada Kedavra who knew right who knew
JP raven fire how's it going JP
Chandler said earlier pizzas already
pick up I'm off looking forward to
catching up a sounds good Chandler don't
hold back on your review give us your
complete and honest thoughts that's
exactly what I wanted this to be so I'm
glad I'm I'm glad to hear you say that
and it doesn't surprise me I mean
guys for those of you who I mean working
with the folks at Avalanche and just the
limited capacity that I have I'm not
gonna pretend like I'm I've known them
my whole life or anything but just like
getting to know them a little bit
at some of these events and through
social media and stuff I mean
they're just great people man they're
great people and no one ever like said
you can't say this or you can't say that
all all this I mean obviously there are
things you can't reveal just yet as far
as like the uh like embargo and stuff
but as far as like your actual opinion I
think they they want to hear what we
really think and they have made that
clear to us throughout the process so
that's that's awesome to see
awesome to see
let's see who else do we have here t
wim1971
care M lot have you been able to 100
there are so many Collectibles and fun
side quests yes I so sort of
I have but I haven't gotten the trophy
for it yet so yeah on my first
playthrough my main character we did get
100 every everything in game is showing
correctly we're good we've gotten 100 on
everything but I can't get the
PlayStation trophy to pop just yet
giving me the validity that I need
however irrelevant it may really be in
the grand scheme of things
I want it I want that little digital
badge of honor saying yes retro you 100
of the game
and I'm sure they'll get to it in due
time
I'm sure it'll happen but it's just they
just have to figure out what's going
wrong with that one
let's see great Aurelius what do you
think portkey Games should do for a
sequel or how they can make a sequel
different oh another sequel question
yeah that's that the answer to that is
coming I have I have so many ideas so
many ideas
Chandler what's your next project hey
good try Jake good try getting him to
solve that
foreign
keep up the good work hello from
Slytherin Draco MacGyver oh you changed
up your name Draco there you go wait we
have two dracos now we have a d we have
a draco underscore MacGyver and then we
have Draco d-r-a
Iko we have that one as well
how do you get the special Discord thing
what special Discord thing Oh you mean
like the the role for being a member you
have to make sure that it's linked to
your you have to link Discord in YouTube
and then it should be like an automatic
thing with the bot
yep should be like an automatic thing
yeah yeah yeah
if not if if you have it all linked up
to where your Discord and YouTube are
linked
then and if it's still not working
I have no idea
all right well
that's a nice welcome in to everybody
appreciate you all being here I think
anybody no one has anything else I think
we're ready to dive in man
I think we're ready to dive in
for the full review
oh wait here's a question from Baxter
anyone know if there's any plans to redo
any more Hogwarts Legacy drops for those
who might have missed one if you mean
the twitch drops they've they said no
current plans
somebody asked that question on Twitter
Baxter I think it was the wbe games
support account that they asked
if you're talking about the twitch drops
yeah those are done and they said there
are no current plans
which who knows that might be that might
be a good idea something they could do
around the launch of the other versions
I don't know
Anna thank you for being here I have to
point out again you love the Sebastian a
thank you so much Anna yeah guys if you
haven't checked out today's video it is
very very spoiler heavy but I've been
telling people for a while
that part of the reason for me going
full time on this content creator
journey is because I want to make
more in-depth
story driven videos I mean we've we've
said from the beginning from the
beginning of this channel just the dad
who loves games and the stories they
tell
and we've experimented with this a
little bit and had some really good
success on videos like the complete
history of the Harry Potter video games
which now we probably need to update
that one right
but
that Sebastian video that we posted
today again full spoilers if you guys
you know if you haven't seen it
and you've played through the game
definitely check it out let me know what
you think because it's it's a little bit
different from the videos that we've
done before I wanted to make it more
like a documentary type feel and giving
people the over
sort of the overview of Sebastian's
story but also putting a little kind of
analysis with it
relating it back to the original series
so thank you for saying that though I
appreciate that yeah the the comments on
it have been great so far
so hopefully as more people play through
the game they'll get a chance to watch
it as well yeah
Joseph I think they will all you think
that yeah it's possible they could do it
they could do another drop thing
whenever uh those versions hit
you enjoyed it moonspark nice thank you
thank you appreciate it you got it
connected Jake nice
hey I appreciate it Baxter thank you for
the support dude I know I know you're
waiting patiently
you're waiting patiently and I'm sure
that they have
you know they're trying to get it out
and get it ready for you guys they they
want all players to be able to enjoy the
game for sure
thank you Karen a lot I appreciate it
soundtrack feel like you put on yeah I
did I did I change up the voice a bit I
I wanted it to be more of a
I mean it you have to it has to be a
different voice I feel like because
normally I mean if I'm doing kind of a
news
type top 10
people of the internet here's your top
10 Hogwarts Legacy gameplay tips
you know it's more fast-paced but when
I'm telling a story
you can slow down a bit
you can pause
you can let people feel the weight
of the words as you say that you know
you can you can use all those things so
yeah
but when I play it back at first I was
just like oh my goodness I don't know
about this I don't know about this I
don't know about this because it sounds
so different from my normal tone
but I had a I had Nico give it a watch
before I posted I was like what do you
think
do I need to like go back and re like
change my voice up
and he's like no I think it fits so
shout out to Nico
shout out to Nico you you enjoyed the
voice good fall asleep to it nice
appreciate that soundtrack yeah
I've tried it once before in another
video
which one was it
going back and listening to it now and
I'm like oh that was two that was too
much it was too too dry
I can't remember what it was now
but my the the video our most viewed
video on the channel
the Hogwarts Legacy kind of preview
video that we did
that is one of the few videos
that I rewrote
most of the whole thing well I rewrote
the intro and then I re-recorded the
entire thing I recorded it one time and
I hated how my voice sounded
I was like no no it wasn't me it was too
it was too sort of
dry and slow paced
and so then I rewrote the intro and
re-recorded again and I was like well
okay I think that was the right move I
think it paid off
I think it paid off all right guys
here's what we're gonna do next we are
going to switch scenes
and when we switch scenes we will
officially move into spoiler territory
so if any of you have to bounce out I
get it understand no hard feelings
and anybody on the replay Squad as well
uh thank you for being here again at the
end of this I'm going to make sure we
have time stamps so people can jump to
any part of the video they want to to
check it out but yeah so just kind of
the overall plan is I'm gonna do well
you'll see you'll see
you shall see let's do this
all right man we have not used this view
in a while
so whenever you need to write something
in depth
hold on I'm gonna kill the music too
I need to focus we gotta Focus here
the slow motion is making you Linger
Longer oh my goodness Anna I can't
believe all this time here you haven't
gotten gifted yet it's that's very rare
we have so many gifteds here
in our in our streams
it's all good though honestly like now
that the game's out we could probably
turn the slow mode off we had to turn it
on like before the game came out man
those streams there were so many people
in there and the chat was moving so
quick it was uh it was hard to manage so
all right so let's pull out the trusty
Notepad
the trusty notepad so let's say Hogwarts
legacy full review
and just so it's clear
PS5 digital Deluxe
and then we should also probably say
copy provided by WB
just for full transparency
oh
thing at the beginning like I didn't
want this to be a traditional kind of
review where you give your Pros you give
your cons you give your summary and
that's it we may do a video like that
eventually
but for this I really wanted us to be
able to kind of drill down deep so when
I consider like what makes a game right
it starts with the gameplay I know I say
I'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
and stories obviously a very important
part of games
but for me it really all starts with the
gameplay if the game is not fun to play
even if it has a great story
and if it's a terrible game then it's
kind of like well what was the point of
that you know
now some games now for Hogwarts Legacy
I'm going to divide it into two major
points we've got gameplay and we've got
story
they weave back and forth they they go
hand in hand in this game it's really
hard to separate the two actually with a
game like this
just as an example for you guys if you
look at something like telltale's The
Walking Dead that goes much heavier
on the story side of things much heavier
on the story side of things and you know
what let me move this I want to move
this just a little bit to make sure that
you guys yeah to make sure you can see
everything there
I don't want any of this to be cut off
so let me just like I'll just tab over
here to make sure
so like Telltale The Walking Dead would
be an example of a game that's almost
all story there's very limited gameplay
then you have other games completely on
the flip side of that where it's like
it's just purely gameplay right that's
it so think of something like pong
even Mario the original Mario be a good
example of you have like the the small
like tiniest bit of a story there and
even to this day Mario games it's pretty
much you know the story changes ever so
slightly
but it all started with that same like
hey the princess is in another Castle
right so games for I mean ever since
games have been a thing they've kind of
balanced these two things uh or you know
in the early days of games it was pretty
much just this right it was pretty much
only gameplay now in more recent years I
mean when I say recent I mean you know
the past two decades or so story has
really
really ramped up right and it's really
increased now you have games being
turned into HBO series The Last of Us my
favorite game of all time turned into an
incredibly incredibly successful TV show
and The Last of Us the reason it's my
favorite game of all time is I've always
felt like it did such a great job
at balancing these two things
of having a really good story and a
really good gameplay
and when they come together it just in
my mind it was my favorite game ever
made
however however I will say there are
times when if the gameplay is really
strong and if the story is just okay you
know you can kind of forgive certain
things right like Eldon ring has a
really
deep story I gotta watch vati video
videos to be able to like understand
everything that's going on there but the
gameplay is incredible right the
gameplay is incredible
so
I don't think it's enough to just put
these two up there right and then we've
got to break them down even further I
can't just say here's gameplay and then
go from there so let's let's look at
what all makes actually it might be
easier to start with story let's bump
story to the top here
bump story to the top
and then we're gonna break up the
elements of the story here so first off
we have
characters whoops I have all caps on
characters are obviously a very key part
of the story
then we have
I would say setting
an environment
and yeah I think it's important to have
both those on there you'll see why in a
second
after that I would say
how do we word this like the main plot
like this is a game that has so many
different plot lines there's so many
different moving pieces to it so I would
say the main let's say the main story
plot
and then we also have companion stories
and then I would say another category
for
just like General World Building stories
so all of those extra
the little letters that you're finding
the the side quests Mary you guys
remember Mary and her spiders yeah
that would be the example of these
little kind of side
extra World Building stories
now it just feels too quiet so I think
I'm gonna bring the music back
all right bringing the music back
Among Us yeah like that's a good game a
good example very limited story The
Division yes yes a lot of multiplayer
games a lot of multiplayer games it's
like yeah they put a story in there but
nobody I mean fortnite yeah there's
somewhat of a story but
it you know we care about the skins and
the gameplay and all that right a little
bit of a story they've kind of expanded
on it but yeah you guys know what I'm
talking about when it comes to that
so I'm gonna go through and I'm gonna
rate each of these things but I'm also
gonna talk through each one of them and
I'm not gonna be like
it's not gonna be like okay seven out of
10 here 8 out of 10 here now we're going
to take the average and give it an
overall story I'm just gonna rate each
element on its own because I think some
things obviously should wait more than
others like the main story should be
more important than the companion
stories
the character yeah you'll see like
certain things are gonna have to wait
wait more than others I feel like
okay let's see would there be anything
else that we would want to break down as
far as The Story Goes
you got characters you've got your
setting environment
you've got the main story plot you've
got companion stories
which probably do companion stories
World Building stories and then we have
our gameplay okay this one
all right this is where it's gonna get
it's gonna get even more complex from
here right so I would say I would give
one called presentation
and for presentation I'm going to say
things like
graphics
performance
I'm not going to say mechanics and stuff
like that yet I feel like that's a
separate all right let's just leave it
at that for now
let's go mechanics
and here in this one we're going to talk
about the combat and the movement
oh there's going to be a lot here
exploration
let's see let me look at my notes and
make sure I'm hitting on everything that
I wrote down
yeah yeah so exploration and then you
have like
the main quests
you have side quests
gear
oh man this is almost like well yeah
that is that is part of the mechanics
like the gear
talents and let's say upgrades system
your gear your talents your upgrades
then you have
because okay when I write this you might
think this belonging story we're going
to separate it out we're going to talk
about Hogwarts how it relates
mechanically to the gameplay and then
we're also going to talk about Hogwarts
as far as The Story Goes
and then I also feel like you need to
have one for classes because that is a
mechanic used in the game
and then I'm gonna say room of
requirement
so that would include everything like
potions and all of that
talents yes exactly Sophia oh ken that's
a good one puzzles okay puzzles I feel
like would almost be a sub
probably a sub-category of the side
quests but yes that's a good whenever we
whenever we talk about that one we need
to make sure that we include puzzles
there
and then last I'm gonna have a separate
category here not necessarily
because I think
here's the tricky thing about games
replayability
when I was a kid I feel like every game
review that I I read
they would they would talk about like
how replayable a game is
and some reviewers it would feel like
they include like they weight that in
their review
when I've never really felt like that
should be
you know if you play an incredible game
even if you never play it again like
does that
does that change is that like somehow
weaken the overall experience I don't
think so
and the example I would give for that is
is Journey
you guys have never played Journey that
game it's a very short game I think it's
even on PC now
but that your first experience to that
game yes you can replay it I have
replayed it
but it's it's never going to match that
first experience it that game has very
little replayability I I would argue
there's very little reason to go back
and replay it
especially once you know the kind of
final like you see how it ends you see
there's somewhat of a little twist in
Journey
so I'm not even if I rated like let's
say I rated this like a two out of ten
or something I'm not gonna let that
affect my overall like score but I still
want people to know what I feel about
the general replayability of a game
because
I feel like it's particularly relevant
for this game because so many people
so many people wanted this to be a game
that they could just like play Forever
which would certainly get into more of
the
of the MMO type gameplay you know
so I've been listening to a lot of
people give their opinions on this game
a lot of people
and
I think the biggest thing I hear is that
a lot of people had in mind their
expectation
even even people who are like I love I I
really do love the game
but I wish it was this other thing that
I that I actually expected I've heard
that from a lot of people
so I'm gonna try to balance that as as
we go through here Austin wintry I know
Austin wintry with uh the soundtrack in
Journey
phenomenal
ethical system
let's see where
because I definitely want to talk about
choice but I almost feel like
oh that's a tough one because that that
one sits right on
right in the middle of gameplay and
story right like any game where you give
me dialogue choices
and you at least give me the perception
of making choices that is something that
affects both story and gameplay oh my
goodness where do we put that
I'm I think we'll talk about that here
I think we'll talk about that here
so let's see how did you word it
you said yes so like the
ethical
morality choices
oh but that I mean that is that is
gameplay too
that is gameplay too but I'm just gonna
put it here right now so we don't forget
about it
soundtrack trying so hard to fight the
urge to give into spoiler so hard to
avoid them I'm Gonna Leave hey
soundtrack it's all good
I understand I understand people not
wanting to be spoiled
yeah we'll be I did see about that I
wonder
I still don't know if they've confirmed
whether it was for Robbie Coltrane but
some people were saying maybe it's for
like a nod to Buck beak
but Buckbeak didn't you know spoilers
but we didn't die I mean I'm sure he did
eventually but not when everybody
thought he did
NPC memory intelligence yeah we're going
to talk about that when we talk about
the uh
like the Companions and then like the
World building I feel like World
building will be where we we cover NPCs
and stuff
or or hold on no we got one for
characters here yeah that's right I
forgot about that
okay oh man this is gonna be fun all
right so now
let's go back up
and let's start going through this so
characters now even within characters
I feel like you have to break this down
further you've got professors
you've got companions
you've got I would say
Quest Giver so this would be like your
Zenobia
um let's see who are some of the other
ones that just give you like a random uh
Samantha Dale
so we'll just say
nobia Dale
Etc
then I'll just say students
so these are just like NPCs
and then I'm going to say
like the towns people
or Hamlet we'll say hamlet
or no no no no no no the uh
Scottish
Highlands NPCs
there we go
yeah Nelly yeah that's another good one
JP exactly
exactly okay
so now I'm going to go through these and
we're going to give each of these like a
score
so professors
and again we're not getting the gameplay
yet so for this we're just focusing on
story
and I'm trying to think of a reason not
to give a 10 out of 10 on the professors
because I thought the professor so going
into this game right it's one thing to
say you're making a game at Hogwarts
you've already got the advantage of the
setting right you know it's a it's a
world that people love already there's a
lot of good systems in place as far as
how the magic works as far as how the
school Works you've got the four houses
you've got all those things that you can
pull from however
if they had just put a bunch of
professors in there
and students and characters for that
matter that we did not care about
that didn't fit within the world it
would have been a disaster it would not
have worked
we may still have enjoyed it but we
would have been very disappointed
so let's just go through the professors
here so you have kind of like your main
tier professors right you've got Ronan
you've got Professor fig
who kind of helps you out you've got
black the Headmaster garlic herbology
you've got
oh I should probably be writing these
down
okay so you've got Ronan got garlic
you've got black
you've got fig
you've got Weasley yes how could we
forget Weasley
uh heck it
oh man and then uh let's see Nat size
mom onai
Madame Kagawa
and then who's the Beast professor
sharp oh yeah how could I forget Sharp
and then the because Kagawa is the
flying instructor right and then the
Beast professor
the Beast Professor slipping my name or
slipping my name slipping my memory
right now
like even as I'm just going through the
names here
and thinking about all of the different
professors that were here
and I would even include I think moon is
not technically a professor
Gladwin Moon maybe he's more like uh
maybe we include him more as a quest
Giver I don't know but he's I feel like
he's more than a Zenobia
I feel like he's a little He's A step
above that
like for now
again just from a story perspective I'm
gonna say 10 out of 10 on the professors
I'm gonna say 10 out of 10. I thought
they fit in incredibly well with the
world
and they gave you just enough of a story
to be interesting however there's more
if you guys didn't do this if you didn't
know about this you can actually go back
and almost all of the professors you can
get more you can get like additional
story about them from talking to them
directly and a lot of them have like a
little private study area
that's it Howlin yes yes yes the Beast
professor professor howin right there
thank you JP appreciate that
and you get this additional backstory
for them like if if I'm gonna knock them
for anything on professors as far as the
story goes it's almost that they weren't
in there enough
like that there wasn't enough with the
professors
because what was there was really good
was really good and the final scene not
the final scene but but the final battle
oh
that was so awesome
that was so awesome that epic scene when
all the professors which by the way why
wasn't garlic there
the Scarlet like taking care of all the
students back at Hogwarts
that is the one thing that I was like
wait a second where's garlic
because I feel like she was in that tier
you know you kind of have like your tier
of the main prevent like the ones that
they announced beforehand
call him staff yeah yeah that's a good
that's a good way of describing it moon
is is kind of like staff there you go
professors and staff yeah
so I'm gonna say I mean if we if I
really wanted to be like hardcore with
this maybe I say a 9-5
let's not even do point scale maybe I
say a 9 out of ten just because I feel
like they could have had even more stuff
with the professors but I'm gonna go 10
out of 10 for now because I really
oh here's the thing that some some
people might knock it for this
I don't personally
but I I get why people would say is that
they were too similar to the professors
that we already know
I mean let's be honest guys like Weasley
clearly taking heavy heavy inspiration
from McGonagall heavy inspiration from
McGonagall sharp I mean you have this
grizzled angry potions Master also
Slytherin
uh let's see now Ronin I feel like Ronin
although
although um
what's his name
not Sprout I keep thinking sprout
Flitwick yeah Flitwick was kind of
I could see some similarities between
Rona but yeah some of them are pretty on
the nose I would say I think that's
intentional because it's it's there to
give you like that little bit of a touch
point
but
but my argument on the other side would
be I think they did a good enough job
once you actually play the game
at seeing that no they're not just
cookie cutters of those characters
Weasley we that's where they could have
done more I feel like Weasley we
probably didn't get enough enough from
Weasley
because Weasley was Weasley was really
cool I mean she's basically having to
run the school because black is just
what's black
I thought they did a great job with
black
thought they did a fantastic job with
black but again it's like I just
wouldn't I just wanted more like I could
have done with more of all the
professors but we'll get into that a
little bit more too when we talk about
classes down here
when we talk about classes as far as the
gameplay okay but as far as The Story
Goes
I give them I give them great job on the
professors
ronan's room in the faculty section is
wild and childlike
uh
uh JP says maybe plants would have been
ineffective in that moment oh in the
battle maybe so maybe so but I mean you
would think she could still do
you think she'd still be good at like oh
I just realized that I'm in top chat
instead of live chat you got to be
kidding me
hope I haven't missed anybody's message
as a result of that
we're taking a long time to pop up you
guys are responding to questions I asked
a while back so that was probably why
that was probably why okay companions
all right
now that the game is fully out I think
it's pretty clear there were only three
companions natsai
Sebastian or Sebastian
you guys like I pronounced it Sebastian
in my in my video today because I
thought
it's so tricky when it comes to names
right because even if you don't speak
that way shouldn't you pronounce
someone's name like how they want it to
be pronounced
I don't know that's that's a tangent a
tangent I probably don't we don't need
to go down that tangent but yeah so when
I did the video today I was like
Sebastian Sebastian and Poppy
okay as characters as characters I I
enjoyed them all I really did
I enjoyed them all obviously I mean I
think it was incredibly incredibly clear
Sebastian got the most time and
attention now I'm not a game developer I
don't pretend to know or understand how
game development works like
I also think it was pretty clear
a meat
at some point
in development
was intended to be a Ravenclaw companion
I mean you even get a mission
where he he is like your companion for
that one mission
but he just like there wasn't enough
there so I don't know if they realized
too late oh wow we need to we need to
add a Ravenclaw companion or if they
just kind of gosh I mean I can't who who
knows how they started like with a game
like this do you start with the story
pieces
or do you start with the gameplay pieces
and then try to fit
that's one thing I it's been so long
since I listened to Neil druckman talk
about this at Naughty Dog With The Last
of Us
and talking about how how they had to
develop those kinds of things so I
he pieced out I know right
right
ominous was great oh my goodness hold on
oh wow so wait we almost need another
category
foreign
because ominous is not a quest giver but
he's not just an NPC either
oh man but his ominous like okay who
else would fit into the ominous category
you guys think about that
we could have learned gobbledygook with
him yes there were definitely there was
definitely opportunity with a meat what
I'm getting at here is I don't know if
it's like maybe they had no idea like I
can't imagine they started out and
they're like okay this this character
Sebastian that's the one he's the one
that's going to be
involved in the main storyline which
really if you think about it
I don't think natsai or poppy were
involved in the main storyline at all
Sebastian definitely came more into play
I mean he had missions with us on the
main story I mean even a meat probably
had more than Poppy and NASA as far as
the main story goes
so yeah I don't know how that works in
development right like maybe they just
had all these great story lines
and then they decide okay we want this
care to take this this care to take this
when did they decide houses is that like
a last minute thing is that something
they decide in the very beginning
it's like at what point and then
remember we're just talking about story
right now because there's the other
issue of the gameplay side of it when it
comes to Companions the gameplay side of
it and how it relates there
tier one tier two companions oh I know
okay right now I'm just gonna say
because ominous e is not just a normal
NPC he's not
I'm gonna call him
oh for now
okay wait I gotta I got a good example
like side Supporting Cast
there we go there we go chat so this
would be like ominous
uh Sebastian's sister and Sebastian's
uncle
oh what is that dude's name Uncle Salah
oh maybe maybe like
maybe some of the vendors
although they're more like NPCs probably
the British pronunciation of status yeah
that's right I did JP
blood status it just didn't sound right
to say status blood status
thank you Sophia Solomon I knew it was
an s
oh like the uh oh well hey I mean we
could say like ran Rock Rookwood there
we go yeah yeah yeah okay
all these I feel like would be
Supporting Cast
all right so let's actually put this
down here
and then a meat
a meat like I was saying I think at some
point he was intended to be more but I
don't know if it's like they got started
on him too late or if they didn't have
enough
so for now I think we have to put a meat
in The Supporting Cast category I have
to put a meat here Harlow yes that's the
I was thinking of her too yep
almost need a whole section with
villains yeah
oh gosh
antagonist right
um
that is that is perfect yes Deke
oh man you guys are good see this is why
we did this live because I knew if I
just did on my own there would be things
I would forget all right I also don't
really like how this is uh
meshing together right here so let's
let's do something like that
so we can see a little bit more of
Separation there
ah
all right so yeah professors they're up
there on their own line
they appear on their own line
dude we're gonna write a dissertation on
the
Hogwarts Legacy
Keepers yes
Sophia that is another good one for
Supporting Cast the keepers all right
but I think I think it's also important
to distinguish here like we I don't
think we need to go and break down and
review every single one of these guys
because they
they all sort of help complete the main
story right
because I feel like your main characters
are these right here
maybe you could I don't know ominous is
really
ominous may very well be main character
same thing for ran Rock and Rookwood I
mean they're your primary antagonists
for the series
load gawk yeah load gok is a good is a
good one and then you have like the VIN
I mean like sirona is more than just a
vendor too
ah
okay so I'm gonna say sirona and then
Etc because there's gonna be
week I feel like The Supporting Cast
we're about to split into another
category right there
mewstor welcome in me store and yeah
that's a good point too Dustin all the
all the all the professors are not main
characters fair enough that's fair
yeah so it's almost like a better way of
breaking this up would have been main
cast
Supporting Cast and then go from there
but yeah that's I don't know if you if
you hopped in late Dustin that's what we
were saying about the professors is just
that
I give him a 10 out of 10 as far as the
story goes but I almost just wish there
was more more with the professors
all right so the companions
seeing the way that everything shook out
with the companions
I definitely think
there should have been a Ravenclaw one
I do but again I have to give Avalanche
the benefit of the doubt here because I
just I don't know how the development
works right but when you when you're
when you see that you've got three
and they're in each of these houses and
then you don't have the fourth
I mean
like what that's where you start to ask
like would it have worked if could you
have kept ominous in Slytherin
and then have Sebastian actually be a
Ravenclaw because
Sebastian's parents were professors even
though he's a Slytherin obviously as you
see throughout the game very a very
cunning Slytherin for sure he clearly
belonged there but his parents
professors he was also very very
studious like he yes he got into trouble
but he always he talked about how much
he loved to read had a thirst for
knowledge he's clearly very smart it's
like what would have happened then like
could you have done that I don't know
but that as far as like raiding what we
what we got Sebastian's storyline was
clearly elevated elevated Above the Rest
so I don't know if it's just they had a
lot of good story ideas and I mean if
for any of you out there who write you
know how it goes I mean sometimes you
just get on a roll and you just have to
to see that one through so maybe it's
like they just had a ton of good ideas
with Sebastian and then the others they
they didn't have as many good ideas so
they couldn't fit them in anywhere
because like what was there of Poppy
I did I did enjoy I did enjoy I think
the fire advice mission
was one of the best missions in the game
fire advice I think was one of the best
missions in the game and had I think as
far as like scale and everything that
sense of scale like when you go in in
that tent I almost wish we hadn't seen
that one early
I don't know it was pretty epic though
getting to to show that as far as a
preview goes
that moment was so epic when you open
that tent and see it's this massive
dragon fighting ring
so that was a pretty cool element of the
story there
for sure
man like do I Want to Break these down
I almost feel like we need to
do the companions
but none of the others we cannot do this
on everyone we'll be here all night
we'll be here all night
okay so Sebastian now I'm not raiding
the character I want to be very clear
about that because I
somebody was looking for hot takes
here's my hot take
I sent him to Azkaban
I sent him to Azkaban dude that man was
a threat to society he was he was he was
on the path to becoming the next dark
lord there's your hot take
if you didn't send Sebastian to Azkaban
you're doing it wrong
I said it I said it chat
yes he has a very tragic past as what we
we talked about in our big breakdown
video today but that dude oh man and
it's all I feel like it's a I mean
obviously he made a lot of bad choices
on his own but it's also I feel like the
uncle played a really big role in that
like like with a little bit more
guidance from uh you gotta remember he's
15. right he's 15. with a little bit
more guidance from an adult an authority
figure in your life
to give I mean come on man like the way
now we the part we don't get to see we
don't get to see what led up to that
right with we don't get to see how
Sebastian and his uncle ended up in the
place they are we get a little bit
alluded to it and all but they I mean
they their relationship is just in a
terrible place so I'm sure Sebastian did
things that he shouldn't have done too
but that Uncle man come on
come on I mean he does it's like he
doesn't even try
he doesn't eat no wonder he goes down
the dark path he doesn't even try
don't consider any of the classmates
companions more like classmates
the tent was a Harry Potter yeah yeah I
love magic I know right
northwood's Nomad I'm doing it all wrong
no I I feel like most people let
Sebastian off I do because
I think this is part of it too most
people went dark arts most people went
dark arts learned the unforgivables from
him you're out here I mean that's um
that oh that almost gets too much into
the gameplay actually
actually no that that touches on the
story part of it too
because
I I wish
I wish it wouldn't have been and I and I
know it's hard to do man I know it's a
video game I know we have to suspend
like our our belief a little bit my
dog's wanting out of the room now all of
a sudden
I know it's like the whole Nathan Drake
thing you know Nathan Drake he's this
great Action Hero who's murdered
countless people
I know but
at a point it's like and and I didn't
know this going into the demo when we
got a chance to play the game early
like in my mind I was hoping that we'd
be able to do like a full
pacifist run right like just
incapacitating dark Wizards and goblins
I don't know tying them up and then the
orders come in or something and take
them to ask man you know come up with
like some sort of mechanic right like
that right like the and you know
Spider-Man games have dealt with stuff
like this over the years yeah you know
they pretend like they never kill but
Spider-Man's launching dudes off a
building is like okay yeah so there's
there's some like a bit of a gaminess to
it where you just have to accept that
but I do wish there would have been a
little bit more like consequence like I
just I just don't know it's it's a
little bit like
it almost takes you out of it a little
bit to when you're just like a 15 year
old
more powerful than Harlow the little the
chief of hogsmeade who can't do anything
who needs you the 15 year old with
ancient magic to like come and take care
of all their problems
oh so yeah I mean that's a little bit of
an issue at least it was for me but
tying it back to what exactly what you
were saying there Northwoods
I feel like most people play Dark Arts
because we a lot of people wanted this
dark power fantasy which I will say I
think clearly after playing the game
clearly like the Canon is is the evil
path I I think I think they definitely
wanted you I mean the rumor was I don't
know if this was true or not but of
course that that long rumor was that it
was really going to be called uh
Hogwarts A Dark Legacy or something like
that right
I think that was one of the supposed
original titles
so I think clearly by putting all of
those curses in the game and everything
and by doing it the way they did I mean
to their credit fans asked for that I I
am I am in the minority on this and I
accept that and realize that fans wanted
the crazy power fantasy it's just a
little bit weird as a 15 year old
now tying it back into Sebastian if you
went down that dark arts path
then I think it makes total sense for
you to not send him to Azkaban because
if you do you're kind of a bit of a
hypocrite right I mean
you're you're just just a wee bit of a
hypocrite there if you're going just as
crazy as he is
and then you send the guy to Azkaban I
feel like you're you're a bit of a
hypocrite however my playthrough I went
I went no dark arts now I was still
taking the lives of countless dark
Wizards and goblins but that's because
that's the only choice like you don't
have a choice not to do that you know
so
characters comments while taking down
the little as the poachers with brutal
yeah
yeah it really was it felt like that of
a much older wizard yeah like an aura
going around and uh
Dustin that Uncle just felt obligated to
take care of the kids I Dustin yeah I
that's where I touched on that some in
the video today I just don't feel like
we know enough about his backstory but
it you definitely get that feel that it
was just at a pure obligation like he
didn't want to have to take these kids
he doesn't seem to care for his brother
much but then you also wonder how much
of that was just like resentment and
disappointment and frustration at how
they died that sort of thing
great Aurelius
great Aurelius guys in the comments said
we needed a morality system like red
dead 2.
how far down this rabbit hole do I want
to go I mean I definitely feel like it
relates here to a review
let's finish the companions
and then I want to talk about wait where
did we we talked about this somewhere
right here okay
I want to come back to that though I
definitely definitely definitely want to
come back to that but as far as like
from my perspective I mean Sebastian was
about to be Voldemort 0.5 before before
Voldemort before Tom Riddle he is on
that path man and I don't even now see
in a sequel they could go anyway with
this right I've seen both endings I've
watched both endings I've seen how it
plays out
but man if you watch that guy shows No
Remorse
No Remorse until
now you think about this he shows no
more shred after it happens he shows No
Remorse after you run out of the cave
and you're out there talking he shows No
Remorse when you get back to the
undercroft and you've had time to cool
down like you can you can go to other
missions he has shown No Remorse the
first time he shows remorse is when
I can't remember if it's the main
character ominous that said I think it's
ominous that says like Anne is trying to
decide if she's going to turn me in
and that's finally the moment he breaks
down he's like what I didn't mean it you
saw me talking to the main character you
saw me I didn't mean it
like dude
Solomon I don't like Solomon Solomon was
not a good
good father figure authority figure he
was not a good
uh caregiver for them he wasn't
but he was not trying to kill his nephew
he was not trying to kill his nephew
that I mean that fight could have went a
totally different way
Sebastian didn't need to bring out the
AK
- he just didn't
so
in my playthrough I feel like I feel
like the only time he shows that remorse
is when he is threatened
and when he is threatened when he hears
Anne oh no like oh crap and I don't this
person that I've been doing all this for
now she's against me I've got I've gotta
apologize I've gotta say I'm sorry I've
gotta I've gotta and I think
you'd be right back on the path again
right back on that path again
now I will say if you choose the ending
to
um spare not spare him or uh but choose
not to send him to uh Azkaban or send
him to trial if you choose that ending
he does have some dialogue that I I will
just from watching it feel sincere it
does it feels sincere
and there is the possibility of of like
a Redemption Arc there
however everything we saw in this game
like I think he's just incredibly
selfish he doesn't listen to anybody
whoever was ready for the hot takes I'm
on a roll now I'm on a roll he doesn't
listen to anybody man
and I get why I
I but it's like ominous tries to tell
him the uncle in his horrible way tries
to tell him the main character
I think now this this would have taken
who knows how many more years of
development I don't know but I would
have loved getting back to this idea of
morality and choices I would have loved
if there would have been a possibility
of you as the character the choices you
make actually being able to somehow
change his path not like fully redeeming
him you know
but
ah just to get him like on the right
track
just to just to at least try and get him
on the right track
so we'll talk more about that in a
second so when I say
that this is a 10 out of 10. it's like
it's like that that storyline obviously
it's the one that got the most love it's
10 out of 10.
okay
I got everything I needed from you
goodbye I know right I know that's how
it felt
Tyler played through all four houses got
the plat Ravenclaw seriously neglected
compared to the other houses
I'm gonna say no we're No Remorse he
seems no I'm like definitely initially
and that's why I was waiting for it when
you get like when you have time to cool
down and you get back
but he even says like I did this for her
I'm like oh no
I did it for you and and when Anne comes
in and like
that line when he's like oh and what
have you done
if if he had shown any other sign like
that line could have almost been him
asking himself like what have you done
like to himself but I've watched that
scene a couple times because I was
trying to figure it out I think he he
was definitely directing it at Anne like
what has she done
what are you talking about
Ryan everyone tried to tell him
like a morality system yeah yeah we'll
get to that we'll get to that one here
in a second Cindy said Sebastian may
have a personality disorder which is
very plausible oh
that's possible he likes when people
agree with him and if you don't you're
the worst enemy yet any any he snaps
it's like really quick too really quick
like when your character just suggests
that I don't know if the keepers will
teach me how to do that like he it's
like instant instantly that guy snaps
oh good question Ken did Sebastian want
to help Anne purely out of love or did
he also want credit as the person who
found the Cure or seemed like a
celebrant thing to do
I don't think he won it I don't think he
cared about credit for the Cure I don't
but I do think he just I think he got so
obsessed with it that
he can no longer see that he was
actually hurting the person that he
loved
and
I mean that's that's like such a hard
thing right like that like it's one
thing to love somebody but I'm telling
you I've been in this deep when I was
making this video this the video we
released today about Sebastian
but it's like at some point
there I mean there's a selfish element
to love there is right there's a lot of
like especially if it's mutual and
you're like in a relationship there's
convenience for both parties there are
things that are mutually beneficial that
both parties get out of being in kind of
a relationship together but there can
become a point where it gets like too
self-centered and two
and I don't even know if it was selfish
but he he he lost sight of what Anne
cared about and like what would help her
because ultimately
in the end
I take I was really anxious to talk to
Anne like in that scene when we finally
get to talk to her and she is I I feel
like that was their way as storytellers
of telling us look there is no cure for
this there is no cure for it
because she says look yeah my uncle and
Seb they mean well my uncle's right and
she's like I can feel it
you gotta think that she and Sebastian
have had have had conversations about
that that's that's a really hard point
man that's a really tough point in a lot
of people's lives you know and I don't
want to get too sad because I know some
of you probably had to go through this
but there there are points in people's
lives you know when
the people that are doing the fighting
they just like it's like they just can
anymore you know and it's and it's
better for them
for you to just like help them live a
peaceful rest of their days you know so
oh it's tough though
it's it's very tough
he just wanted to save his sister
Slytherin Behavior was that he couldn't
take no for an answer yeah the injustify
the means exactly
oh what did Christy say about you have
you have to really mean it and he did at
least in that moment
like Anakin yeah I've heard a lot of
people describe him like see the Anakin
Skywalker Skywalker vibes okay I think
we could have done a whole episode on
just Sebastian maybe we'll do that
another day all right so natsai natsai I
I enjoyed natsai's Quest
I just feel like they both kind of paled
in comparison to
to Sebastian's I do
so let's say okay on our little scale
here let's say like 7 out of ten is good
so they have an out of 10 is good I feel
like poppies was
I feel like it was good
and I still say fire and vice one of the
best missions in the game but we're even
from a story perspective natsai
6.5
6 out of ten
there just wasn't
Poppy I feel like she just kind of came
in too late Nancy at least came in
earlier
so you got a chance to get to know her a
little bit more in the beginning whereas
poppy was just kind of I thought poppy
had one of the best uh I loved the fact
that you learned her she she's from a
family of poachers I thought that was a
cool twist that I I didn't see coming
but yeah these just I don't know they
felt too
poppies was good it was good and nad's
size was good there was just I don't
know
Dustin that's I was better than poppy
pop it was a five Nancy 6.5 is good
maybe I'm over
it's possible I'm overscoring poppy just
because of fire and vice
oh but Nat's eye hold on Nats I had
the uh rescuing High Wing oh
oh man okay here's what we're gonna do
just for the rescuing High Wing we gotta
bump that up
oh wait hold on we said we weren't gonna
do 0.5s We're not gonna do 0.5s
oh
and that was such an epic moment when
you rescue High wing and you get to fly
all poppy did was Chase an ancient
creature in the NAT side questline it
did have a purpose yeah it did have and
and to be fair Dustin we are just
focusing on story so I think you're
probably right from a story perspective
Nat size maybe had a little bit more to
it all right you convinced me we'll go 7
10 there and 610 Poppy
okay Supporting Cast
and again we're just I'm not relating
I'm not necessarily we're gonna get to
the overall main story here in a second
but as far as like The Supporting Cast
goes
I would give them a solid like nine out
of ten
oh wait hold on we could just review
this up here
maybe eight out of ten I was
disappointed in the bad guys
I was disappointed in Rand Rock and
Rookwood I thought they probably played
it a little bit too safe with the main
story they took all they took all the
risks on the the sallow quest line I
feel
so it's good to see them take some risks
to do something bold like that but I
wish I wish they would have went went
with something like that for Rand Rock
and Rookwood not not an exact copy of
that
but it was just too I kept waiting for
some some kind of twist you know
every Potter book is known now again
like the Harry Potter books they're very
popular for a reason right they were
they were very just like amazing stories
that had awesome a lot of them had
awesome twists at the end so it's I
don't want to make light and act like
it's an easy thing to do
but they just didn't have that big kind
of
they just didn't really have that that
moment right they didn't have that that
wow moment like like that one did
I mean my jaw I was not expecting Seb to
AK Solomon I was not
I was not expecting that at all ominous
one of my favorite characters in the
game I love the turn that he I love how
he starts off you think he's this
annoying Draco Malfoy he even kind of
has that my my father voice you know
Nats is seven Roundup because High Wing
the High wig part was amazing too for
sure
or sure
so yeah I'm feeling good about an eight
there the keepers was cool but
I get that they wanted to make them
completely new characters
I get that
I know
the Merlin conspiracy theorist himself
isn't too happy about that
but I get I get why they wanted to tell
kind of Their Own Story
ominous again fantastic and when she was
on screen you know she was good Solomon
like from a character perspective
good character really bad uncle really
bad at dealing with grief and loss
ran Rock and Rookwood like I said I just
wanted I just wanted more Nuance there
what's so interesting about ran rock is
you actually
you get more Nuance from him in a side
mission that doesn't even like he I
don't think he's even in that mission we
talked about this on one of our previous
live streams I think is that he
you learn why is the way he is
and I'm like that's a big enough deal
that I feel like that should have
been in the main story
I feel like that should have been part
of the main story
Deke is great
sirona's cool I love how sirona stands
up to the
to Rookwood Rookwood man
there was so much potential with
Rookwood
there was so much potential there and we
all called it I mean we we kept saying
for months in the lead up to the game
like they're totally gonna turn on each
other
and then like nothing came off it
there were no there were no consequences
so I do wish there would have been a
little bit more
especially with with the bad guys
ominous is cool because he's a freaking
blind wizard right like the way he gets
around yeah ominous ominous had so many
great moments
so many great moments Deke yeah I like
dick a lot Harlow is useless how does
Harlow still have a job
if you've done the PlayStation exclusive
Quest guys
oh man the end of that one is hilarious
because she's just like
stop her
wait wait why did you just okay you're
you want the 15 year old to take over
all right
Carlos so yeah Harlow dude next game we
take over for Harlow
we are gonna we're gonna get hired in uh
hogsmead
oh my gosh should be going an hour 28
but that's okay we've probably been
going about an hour on story
all right let's go through these quickly
then Quest givers
from a story perspective guys so we're
not we're not reviewing like their
actual like the mechanics of the quests
or anything like that just like from a
story perspective I thought they were
solid
I thought they were solid
because you know you don't expect all of
them to have uh Lucan
bradleby would be another one there
you don't expect them to have some big
huge plot like the others and they don't
have to I mean that's just
that'd be really hard to fit all of that
into a game
for that many different characters
so I'm actually thinking
um
again we're not reviewing the quest
we're just reviewing like
kind of the overall how they play into
the
the story
yeah like cross wands is cool getting to
see that and how I just I wish there was
more cross ones but that
that does tie into story but I feel like
that's more gameplay
students NPCs
in my first
20 hours of the game My First like just
like initial review initial recap of
things I rated this as a pretty big
weakness because there are so many that
you come across who are just like
standing there just staring they never
move
that's it
I will say I feel like I was maybe a
little bit too hard on it
because the more I've played the game
the more I have picked up on there's a
lot of extra conversations that I don't
think everybody's even
seen yet
I was walking by a group of students the
other day on my second playthrough and I
heard someone mention a line of
quidditch that I had not heard before so
I went back and I just stood there for
like 15 minutes because I was like I'm
just gonna see I'm gonna see if this
will repeat
and it took a good 15 minutes they kept
talking
and it probably took
about 10-15 minutes for them to finally
get back to
what I heard them say about quidditch so
there was a lot of dialogue there
between the characters however that
whole time there was a group sitting
beside them that they were just like
staring into space never said a word
and then I do think it's a little weird
uh from the attic fellow content creator
had a really interesting video that I
was watching the other day
and he talked about how like in the
original bully a very old game
you could go and you could talk to
could talk to all the students
now of course that's running on very
different hardware and you know not
nearly as much going on in the
background as everything Hogwarts Legacy
has going on
but I I was surprised that you couldn't
talk to more students there was only
like after classes was like the one time
you could do it right after a class
would happen there would be these
options you would see the little
indicator above their head you could go
and talk to a lot of the students that
stuff was cool but it was like only
right after the classes
so this one it's it's a bit of a mixed
bag for me sometimes it's great
sometimes it's great you'll walk by and
you hear a really cool conversation
happening
but it's like you can't you can't say or
do anything
you can't say or do anything yeah Blue
Moon exactly lots of random
conversations you just can't partake in
them yep
see a student stuck in the air yes that
one was so funny there's another one
where this happened to me late game you
go up in the hospital wing
and there's a student in there
with a goat
and they they claim that it's their
friend who has been trying to become an
animagus and that they are the goat oh
it's so funny the dialogue on that one
is so good
so it's like stuff like that was so good
but then there there are too many times
when it just feels
a little bit dead when it comes to the
NPCs
so I'm really torn on this one like I
don't know
in terms of a score I don't even really
know how to score I mean I'm kind of
like in the six to seven kind of range
like initially initially I would have
probably been at a 5 out of 10 because I
was pretty disappointed when I first
started the game the first 20 hours but
the more you play it you will see more
conversations and like the goat one I
mean you see these hilarious ones you
guys see you haven't even seen that one
Dustin I'm sure there's some that I
haven't seen either
so I still feel like there's a lot that
people haven't found
I'm gonna go six out of ten
and it's like what like the stuff that's
in there when it's when it's really good
it's it's so good but then when it's
it's not you have you'll see like this I
saw this this one Gryffindor looked like
a first-year student I pointed them out
in my first impressions video
I see that dude standing in the same
spot all the time
all the time you know there's like no um
at least from what I I could see there's
not really any routine to the characters
like I was thinking man maybe you're
gonna have characters that like actually
well you know what sometimes there is
because I saw them I saw a bunch of
Slytherin students leaving the common
room one time
so I guess there is somewhat of a of a
routine to it
uh Scottish Highlands okay NPCs as far
as Story Goes uh that's like a lot of
the vendors and stuff all the little
extra stories like Mary and her spiders
or no that's going to be in World
Building stories it down here oh my
goodness are we even gonna get through
story in this review are we even gonna
no routine there's been people that
followed them and they run into walls
and keep walking the Frog let loose in
central Hall I don't think I've seen
that one care
I do not think I've seen that one
thought our companions were gonna assist
more go on more quests yeah yeah I agree
Ryan I think that I think we'll get into
that more when we get into gameplay here
I think we'll get into that there
foreign
we never get through everything we need
to dude I was like okay a solid two
hours will be plenty of time to go
through like game plan story those are
gonna be my big my big things
but as far as like the vendors and
everything goes
I mean I'll say like eight out of ten on
that because I don't feel like they need
to be like that one it's it doesn't wait
as much as the students like the
students Hogwarts that's our main place
that's where we're at all right this
one's easy
this one's easy man 10 out of 10. like
the castle
the highlands exploring all of it from a
story perspective I mean you already
knew that though right that's why we're
interested in the game Hogwarts Legacy
that was our main reason for being
interested is because it takes place of
Hogwarts
10 out of 10. that's an easy one main
story plot
we touched on this a little bit here
when we were talking about Rand Rock and
Rookwood
I'm hovering somewhere between like a
seven and an eight
somewhere between like a seven and an
eight and you know what companion
stories I'm taking that one off because
we just we did that up here
oh and if we're so for like raiding
companions as a whole
I don't think we need to do that
we'll say
I'll say like an eight out of ten
overall
oh maybe and and
Ravenclaw
definitely needed
uh I'm just gonna say like
a meat a meat should have been
fourth companion
setting yeah 10 out of 10 the main story
so okay
here's what I liked here's what I liked
ancient magic stuff I thought was cool I
thought that was very smart
to choose something like ancient magic
that's in the book but it can impact our
gameplay and it can impact the story as
well
the beginning
incredible
again no gameplay yet incredible the
Gringotts section
how great was that how great was that
my biggest issue is that there wasn't
more of that like I thought and again
this is where we start to get into
expectations you know and what you were
thinking and expecting
but I thought it was going to be
like once that happened I was so pumped
because I was thinking dude
there's going to be missions where we go
to Ministry there's going to be a
mission where we go to Azkaban no I'm
not counting the Hufflepuff one even if
you do right even if you do
there wasn't a lot there to that I was
thinking they were going to be full-on
missions where we leave the castle I
mean it's a world where you you can
operate you can do Port key you can do
our main character finds these these
portals right I mean there were so many
ways they could get a student to these
other locations
so I think it's like they they put so
much time into that beginning I know
they I mean they've talked about how
much time they put into that beginning
but then we just never went anywhere
else like that
we never went anywhere else like that
and again I'm not even counting the ask
Bama because it was I mean it was cool
for hufflepuffs don't get me wrong but
it was such a short thing and you I mean
you basically just have one long haul
and that was it
but as far as the plot goes like I
touched on it up here I wanted more from
Rand Rock and Rookwood
that this the sallow quest line that's
where they took the big risks
and
the haunted hogsmeade Quest dude oh my
goodness
that was insane
so like more they needed more like the
sallow quest line in in this part and I
don't feel like we can talk about the
main story without talking about the
main character now this is another one
where I've listened to a lot of
different people give their take on this
a lot of different people
and I still struggle with the fact that
we didn't have more backstory for our
character I know it's meant to be The
Witcher wizard you want to be
but it's hard like like there's no
reason to
there's no reason to care about your
character right away there's no reason
to
to care about the the mission like
you're just you're in that Carriage at
the beginning and it's like oh like
what's this blue what's this blue stuff
I'm seeing
Big's like what
we were totally wrong about that by the
way remember how we thought fig like
maybe that's the whole reason we're
starting late is somehow we like
what have we been doing
for five like not we didn't we didn't go
to magic school
anywhere I know we didn't go to Hogwarts
and clearly our character understands
the magical world because we understand
terms and everything but I mean do we do
we have a family like is there anybody
we care about
anybody anybody at all that we care
about
or are we just so I don't know it was it
was
again I get why but I wish I wish there
had been more on that
and then here I know this touches on
gameplay too
but you guys have brought this up a few
times in in the comments and I really do
feel like this game needed
some sort of
Choice based
where more choices matter
now I know
you gotta be
you got to understand the limitations
because any game all games have
limitations right
so as much as I love games like heavy
rain in The Walking Dead those games are
very light on gameplay because
they have to put so much of their
resources into the storytelling and
giving you all these these branching
paths for the dialogue options dude out
Heavy Rain my first experience through
Heavy Rain was one of the
most entertaining gameplay experiences
I've ever had if you guys have not
played heavy rain
oh my goodness that game is so like like
the choices that you have it's just so
good and you can have I can't even
remember how many different endings they
had
so I I understand and and that's why
it's
it's hard to just like go crazy you know
knocking them too hard for this because
it's that is a Monumental task to be
able to do something like that
but
you look at Mass Effect
you look at Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic
oh man I don't think you have to go full
Mass Effect but Knights of the Old
Republic
is still to this day one of the one of
the coolest stories I mean I'm I'm not I
wouldn't say like I'm a big Star Wars
fan
I enjoy Star Wars but I'm not like a
hardcore fan that's seen everything
about it but dude Knights of the Old
Republic
incredible story
incredible story and there are so many
things in that game where your choice
matters like your your dialogue the
thing that you say they're not gonna
forget into it it could impact
what happens to that character it's like
you have a lot more of the Sebastian
situation in that game
and and
ERS you love Kotor as well Dustin one of
your favorite games of all time absolute
favorite
and the main story major Major Spoilers
if you guys haven't played Knights of
the Old Republic here
that is a such a good example of doing a
story and letting you be like your own
character so if you don't know the way
you start that game Something's Happened
your character has this Amnesia you
don't remember you wake up on this ship
you're like what the heck is going on
and then so all game you keep this this
bad guy is uh Darth Malek keep hearing
about Darth Malek and Revan and Malik
and nobody knows what happened to Revan
what happened to Revan nobody knows
and then you get to one of the greatest
plot twists in all of Gaming
you are Darth Revan you are no matter
what the choices are that you've made
because you can go good or evil in that
game you can go Jedi or Sith and it just
works so well because if it's like
if you go if you go the good route then
it's just like
oh my goodness you know I'm a new person
now I can't believe I did all these
things and then if you go the bad route
oh I can't even remember how
I can't remember if I replayed that or
not
if I replayed it as a Sith
but that game I feel like is such a good
example of giving you
lots of different choices and actually
having them have weights and matter
and I was I was a little bit worried
when they first came out and said we're
not going to have a morality system it's
because there's so I mean there's so
many different ways you can Define like
a morality system you know is it like
Infamous where you have oh you made a
bad choice so you're gonna go One Step
Closer on this scale
I don't know that it needed to be like
that and then you make a good choice oh
and that bumps you back
but there I mean there is a point where
man if you're casting Avada Kedavra
like crazy
other characters are seeing you doing it
I mean
and we we sort of joked about this
before the game came out it's like
what's gonna happen are the teachers
just gonna swarm you is is the ministry
gonna a group of ores gonna run in no
none of that happens
none of that and I would argue I mean
the story the choice that you make at
the very end of the game I would argue
is not even that I mean
it's just so little difference
there's just so little difference though
the only choice that I think even makes
that big of a deal is is the Sebastian
one
the sallow quest line
so
all of that I think I've talked myself
into
six out of ten
seven out of ten
Sebastian choice you agree Sebastian's
the only one that really met Detroit
become human oh my gosh that's by the
same developers that did Heavy Rain
right yeah I need to play that one I did
not get to play Detroit
me oh wait what are you responding to
Christy I'm behind now
Sebastian is the only one that really
matters yeah I mean that's like that
choice
I'm gonna go six out of ten for now
oh AKA
yeah yeah yeah casting AK everywhere
crucio imperio
I mean think about it was such a big
deal in the series when
like Harry when they use it in book
Seven when they use Imperial and the
Goblins like that
that was something they really had to
wrestle with but then it's also at times
like the uncle is so over the top with
him using imperio I mean I know it was
kind of dark when he makes the goblin
just like
but it's like come on there there are
degrees here imperio
not on the same level as crucio or AK
depending on what you make the person do
I guess and in his case he went to the
goblin so that's why the uncle just lost
it but
World Building stories
this is like Mary and her spiders
I liked them I think there were there
were some really good ones
and these don't necessarily have to oh
dude here's what I will say oh this is
more about the main quests
but I'm just gonna go ahead and write it
down here right now
needed longer
quests I'll expand on that more when we
get there
so the world Building stories again
they're they shouldn't be as important
to the overall score as like the main
story plot
but yeah I liked a lot of the world
Building stories I loved how they
brought in elements that we know from
The Wizarding World like
sakurisa tugwood great example the quiz
the little quiz that you can take
that was so good I love that I love that
the the goat the random little side
stuff
uh the Gladwin Moon and all that like
all these little extra stories that
don't factor into
the main story but it's all like World
building you know it's all part of the
World building
I mean I might be persuaded to go nine
on this one kind of thing at eight eight
out of ten nine out of ten
and the only reason I would bump it down
to eight is just because
you do have to kind of
the troll that this woman thought she
could train oh
lady that thought she could train the
troll but but she was doing it for like
self-defense for her
for where she lived because of all the
raids and stuff then you kind of feel
bad for it but it's like oh come on you
poor sweet thing
trying to train the troll
what else I think we'll stick with eight
out of ten we gotta move on to gameplay
we gotta move on to gameplay
nine out of ten for side quests World
building quests so much better than the
main story and two-thirds of the
campaigning questline
um
yeah I just think with both the main
story and the world Building stories I
almost wish there had been
it was very like go do this you're done
go do this you're done some of them had
multiple steps to it but it was more
like uh
like the Alby weeks like oh here's the
broom upgrade okay I got another one for
you
whereas like like I wish there was more
stuff like the uh companion quests like
where they were multiple steps
okay that is it for story
that is it for our story review so we
broke down the characters the professors
companions The Supporting Cast Quest
givers all that now
hour and 50 minutes all right let's see
if we could do this in an hour let's see
if we can do this in an hour
you guys think nine
I'm gonna stick with eight but I we will
let the record show that chat
the majority of chat here are kind of
leaning more toward nine on the World
building stuff
all right um presentation and grab like
I almost want to put this one at the end
like that's just
that's a technical thing that you that
you hope
shouldn't matter
so I'm gonna bump that I'm gonna bump
that down
we'll talk about that towards
all right combat and movement
this is where if we're not I was about
to say this is where we get really deep
we're we're pretty much really deep
already but let's we're going to take a
look at another layer now
so combat itself
and I I almost feel like I gotta bump up
gear talents and upgrades we have to
talk about that in relation to combat we
just have to
it doesn't make sense
we have to touch on that here
so I'm gonna say like
ridiculously fun
it the combat is so fun
um the combos are great spells
spells and the enemy like weaknesses
work so well together I love all that
stuff
I I absolutely love all that stuff
like I I would say I'm comfortable
saying the combat
is a 10 out of 10. moving around your
character navigating about the world all
of that feels great they really
they really did a great job with that
I've talked about some minor stuff like
with with the spell diamonds and how I
wish we could slot more spells like I
think the room of requirement needs to
be a totally separate spell thing like
that you shouldn't have to slot them
and then there are even other things
like the Beast bag like why couldn't
that have been contextual little things
like that but just overall
the combat was so fun I will say now I'm
still giving it a 10 out of 10 but I'm
still gonna give like some constructive
I would have liked to see more enemy
variety
more boss battles
and even like I would say like mini
bosses
and just like like lean more into the
combat like this would be positive I
guess neither positive nor negative but
like more
how would we word this one
like I love the fight with the giant
Knight and with ran rock at the end like
having to use like all these different
skills that you've gathered like having
to switch to multiple spells
I would have loved to have seen if they
would had even more time like what are
what are some other
crazy ridiculous
scenarios so
combat scenarios
more combat scenarios
for using
different spell combos
10 out of 10 from Dustin on combat
needed more Wheels yeah exactly best
part of the whole game says Dustin
Alexis welcome in Craig how's it going
for combat was it'd be good yeah exactly
mu stores has nine out of ten
uh t-w-i-m agree about the spell slots
more than the infamous foes oh the
infamous foes were fun
those were good and that's a good
example but I maybe I'm getting too far
we'll see maybe I'm getting too far into
this one the reason I wanted to move
this up here
is because
this is such a crucial part I feel like
the gear the talents the upgrades all of
that stuff
on its own is a 10 out of 10 for me
I love I love everything about it
however
it's not needed
and what I mean by that is I don't wish
they had taken it out of the game I wish
they had given you
I wish there were scenarios that
required it so I'm gonna bump it all the
way down to seven out of ten and we'll
explain more here because so
talents
and upgrades or here let's just let's
just blow that down so upgrades
themselves are fantastic
few scenarios that require them
and and requires not even the right word
but it's just like you become
so ridiculously overpowered
really fast
really really fast
and it's like you have like all of the
the the traits hold on did I call it the
wrong thing
the traits are so fun
and I was I was so looking forward to
specking out different types of gear for
different scenarios and different
situations
to be like okay when I go tackle this
dungeon or this area I know there's a
ton of this enemy in here so I need to
make sure I have defendo my diffendo
maxed out to take care of these guys
so it's almost like you know I don't
want it to turn into a
like a DPS situation right like Destiny
it's like okay what's gonna do our Max
DPS in this area
but I do feel like there wasn't enough
they they just weren't you don't even
need them like you could go through the
whole game
I bet you could go through the whole
game without ever putting on any traits
and probably be fine in fact I almost
did just that
because I was I was thinking okay I'm
gonna get to a point near the end of the
game where these are actually going to
be really important and I'm not going to
even be able to
take down certain enemies without having
more traits and stuff but you just
become
so overpowered and not that overpowers
being
it's not necessarily bad but there's
just once you once you have like once I
finally got my character like yes these
are all the traits I want
I'd done everything I'd done everything
and so there was nothing else for me to
do there was no nowhere for me to to use
all of those traits
now I saw somebody say Nobu talk about
the gear system is trash
what I think you mean
Nobu is more involving exploration
and I'm not going to say it's it's trash
but what I will say is that oh man is it
exploit no I think it's I think it goes
under exploration
the reward
a big problem
with Rewards
I mean the system that they had in place
the way they structured it was
it's like you could see they were almost
there
they were almost there but when you go
through it through this Cavern and you
solve a puzzle like the caverns
themselves were so cool they were they
were great but I have 100 of the game
and there were some Caverns that I never
had to go into there were some puzzles
that I never had to solve
because
gear is just not rewarding enough
and so you go through these and I've
heard like this is almost across the
board
I like everybody kind of jokes about it
it's like
even the people that love the game you
know me I mean I love the game I'm going
through these areas and I'm just like oh
here we go with another
you solve this fun puzzle and it's like
oh I got a purple scarf
and it's actually lower than the one I
had before
and because of the SE of the transmog
system
all you're really getting
out of that is
you're just getting another cosmetic
that's really it
now what I will say is it's a big
challenge with a game like this it is a
big challenge
because of the way it's like you can't
go
you know if you're in a game if you're
in a game like Eldon ring eldering is a
good example of this
you have so many different weapon types
you can find this awesome ax then the
next one you can find this amazing sword
then you could find some just like crazy
Off the Wall weapon that you didn't even
know existed
in this game in the world they're in
they don't really have that option
so it's like what do you do what what do
you do I that's this is where like I'm
just a reviewer I'm not a developer I
don't know what the solution would be
but for a sequel
I think they would have to figure this
out
I think they would really have to figure
this out or I mean dare dare say
I'm not gonna say not do it at all
because
because I do like that sense of like
going out and finding rewards here's
another good example we'll probably do I
mean I'll delete this but just because
it's fresh on my mind uh the division
versus Destiny now I don't play much of
either of these games anymore
but one of the things that made
Destiny's loot system so
addictive now you may say addictive is
good or a bad thing I don't know but for
me the reason that I wanted to literally
grind strikes grind raids over and over
and over and over again
is because of the
what would you call it it's like the
loot has personality
and so if your destiny if you ever take
play Destiny I'm talking about things
like fatebringer
Gallo horn
dude did I spell that right
that's close
Etc all like the like the weapons
themselves almost become characters the
division which is which was I a game I
enjoyed but it's just like
upgraded AK
slightly better
sniper
sniper stock
exactly Dustin like Elden ring
and that's where I again I just come
back to I don't know what the solution
would be I I don't know
I I don't know I don't know how you do
that in the Wizarding World
because almost everything like even if
you included every
think about every tool that you could
have in the Wizarding World
now if I really sat down like if I took
a lot of time and tried to figure it out
I'm sure and and they like I trust
Avalanche in a sequel I absolutely trust
them to be able to come up with things
like this
but me sitting here right now someone
who's never made a video game in my life
I don't know
I can give you examples of other games
like exactly like you just said right
there
and that to your point you said you
don't really understand like division or
destiny think Destiny completely
different game from Eldon ring but it's
more along the lines of Eldon ring and
it's like it's Unique
it is unique the weapon it has a name
it's not just
oh there's that there's the Red Cloak
no oh like the daily in case Quest
reward
that's an example of like a 10 out of 10
one right
10 out of 10. that reward is so worth it
it's so worth it but then you have all
these great like as far as the
exploration goes that's where this one
is really hard to review because
honestly the exploration one of my
favorite things to do in the game
room flight
awesome
um I love the animals as well
uh neat hold on needs dragonflight
I'm gonna I'm gonna give a positive for
hippogriff and thestral
but I'm gonna be 100 honest with you
guys
I never used them
hypocrick whoops
I I use them very occasionally they're
they're like the great they're great for
that Scenic shot but the broom is just
so much more convenient now I have heard
some people complain about the broom
controls a little bit it was a little
bit awkward at first but once I got
going I didn't have too much of a
problem with it
but like all the little
all the little discoverables like
discoverables
in the points of interest
pois
hogsmead I thought all that stuff was
great
the caverns and and the puzzles
vendors
I liked all that
I really did I liked all that stuff
they can add more uniques unique wands
that have special traits but see that
breaks the lore
that's like anything that would break
the lore so much hey because you're 100
right that's absolutely something you
could do like imagine you find
you fight Rookwood you beat him you pick
up rookwood's wand and all of a sudden
like that wand is plus 10
dark arts or whatever I mean yeah you
could do stuff like that but that is
completely lore-breaking
especially when it comes to wands
especially when it comes to wands just
just completely lore breaking
if anything the wand should perform
worse for you
it should perform worse
mounts are slower than the starter Brew
I know dude it's like I feel like the
mounts are just they're great for the
visuals
exploration was fantastic hard puzzles
very well hidden spots yeah like see all
that is great that's why I
because like all of that stuff on
exploration is a 10 out of 10. let's you
know what let's separate this out
I'm gonna I'm gonna just say talents
traits
and upgrades
here we're gonna say gear
loot
and I'm going to say like
4 out of ten
on that one
for all those reasons that we just
talked about
is just you you you almost never feel
rewarded
almost never feel rewarded
or puzzle solving
it's like the reward the reward is in
the journey and the reward is in the
desk is is in the uh
finding it like there was a bunch of
stuff it's like I would just do it
because it was fun I wanted to say yeah
but if you're gonna put if you're gonna
have the loot in there
you gotta make it feel worthwhile
collect the dark whiz collect the wands
with the dark Wizard's date if you get
oh that's dark like you have them on a
displayed on a wall
yeah the pindo puzzles were cool
they were cool they should have given
the brooms traits that's an interesting
idea Alexis yeah
Merlin trials didn't have good Rewards
oh the Merlin trials that'll we'll get
to them in side quests we'll get to them
inside Quest but yet honestly like if I
had to boil down
this is I feel like this is a really big
big thing that whole when I say it holds
the game I mean it definitely holds the
game back from being
amazing well it is amazing I think the
game I think the game is amazing
but it could have been better no doubt
it could have been better and and this
is one of those areas but it's just like
how do you do something like
let's go down here
and let's say
um actually this is going to be a
positive for sure
the daily and keys Quest big positive
plus the reward
so it's like the the dailing keys Quest
and the reward it was worthwhile yes it
was a longer lengthier one but it was
absolutely worth your time
how do they do more like that
with a vast open world
I mean because like Cosmetics they'll
take you pretty far like they did they
did some great a great job with the
cosmetics
I mean if you start doing stuff like
I don't know armor and defense which
like like the offense and defense for
your armor the way they really handled
that was with their traits that's how
they handled that
it's almost like you would want your
traits to be a lot of the
of the rewards for this right here
but then you get back to the problem of
here of like there's just a few
scenarios where they're even needed
a few scenarios where they're even
needed you know
Cloud Roth how's it going welcome in
definitely need more variety in the
Merlin trials
we'll get to Merlin trials we'll get
there
but yeah this this was a big one for me
that you almost never feel rewarded
I feel like I'm kind of delaying here
because I want to come up with some
solutions but that's not the point of
this we're just we're just reviewing
what's there all right main quests
now I feel like this obviously ties
directly back into
uh story
which we gave we gave main story 6 out
of ten so we ended up on the main story
needed longer quests
I would say like multi multi-layered
and then what do I mean by that exactly
like
because I guess the I guess the main
quest did have a lot of steps like when
you consider and I don't mean just like
going around on on fetch quests or
something
I don't know maybe that's not fair maybe
it's not fair to say longer
but they did start to get a little
the whole area with the uh the knights
like that area you you found yourself in
there
a little bit too often but then you get
to the to the one that's like the uh the
third trial was it the third trial that
was the Deathly Hallows right
third trial
huge Plus
I just did the first trial last night
like for the first one I think that's
fine
what was the second trial
anybody remember
uh fire and vice
these great great side quest that's a
poppy one
uh I'm just gonna say like pretty much
all of
sebs quests oh the natsai mission
with rescuing High wing
second trial similar to the first okay
that's probably why all right so we'll
put that one in the minus like second
trial a little bit repetitive
and I I'll give I'll say the final
mission
I thought was great like I
I know some people didn't love like ran
Rock turning into drag I I was fine with
it I thought it was awesome I already
mentioned the way all of the professors
arriving that was so epic dude I got
chills in that moment
I got chills
that was just so fantastic
wait what was the fourth trial fourth
was a joke Cloud says
what was the fourth one
I can't remember
I can't remember what the fourth one was
that was that that was the fourth trial
oh my goodness
oh
yeah
okay hold on we're getting
let's bump this down
it's like the most in-depth review of a
game ever
did come way too late like I can't even
believe that was the fourth trial
fourth trial
way too late for crap horn
lord of the shore yeah yeah you guys are
right
Nobu I agree those are really fun we're
gonna get to that one when we get
I almost am separating out the Hogwarts
side stuff
but yeah I'll go ahead and put that one
in here right now I totally agree with
you
the pulso puzzles
awesome
the third should have been the last uh
yep
yep that was in that was so cool
the third trial guys is the is the
Deathly Hallows one
yeah that was that was really fun
oh yeah when Luke does Luke's Luke's had
a couple on Hogwarts already yeah
he has had a couple
but yeah I'm sure he'll probably be
doing more
all you disk oh dude I love the the
pulso puzzles some of the most
challenging
things in the game
but I I like the challenge I do I love
the challenge of them
Professor Rackham Isador now our
character are the only ones that started
Hogwarts as a faithier or also the other
keepers
I don't think the other keepers
I don't think the other Keepers Joseph
and that in fact I don't think they
could even see ancient magic the same
way that Rackham and Isadora could
okay now this is where I think we also
can touch on the lack of a
companion system
or like of a True Companion system I I
don't
I don't even know if I'm gonna put it as
a negative because I don't personally
mind it too much
but I I feel like I've heard from a lot
of people that so let's just write it in
here for now I'll kind of see what you
guys think if you think it should stay
or not I think some of you actually
already mentioned it
lack of a
True Companion system
Alexis thinks the issue is Avalanche
maybe wanted to complete the main quest
first then do the side quest after it
most people wanted to savor the game and
we're saving it for later
yeah mine got a little weird with
Sebastian because I I think I completed
things in a different order than Maybe
what they had intended or were hoping
but yeah I'm not sure which
I'll definitely say in the beginning
and I heard somebody else in the review
said this too and I was like I totally
agree with you man
if you're watching this right now I
can't imagine you haven't played the
game yet but if anybody out there hasn't
played it yet and you're watching right
now don't
immediately start trying to explore
everything
I feel like it was a little bit too
hand holding in the beginning
um I don't know if this really relates
to main quests I mean I guess it kind of
does
two handholdy
in the beginning and I know there was so
much they needed to get out and tell us
there were so many different systems
that we had to be introduced to I mean
you could be like I think on my first
playthrough I don't think I got the
broom until like I was at hour 10 or
something and so what a lot of people
wanted to do right away is they just
wanted to go explore they just wanted to
go crazy I that was me you know I I
walked around the castle I I just I was
like I'm just gonna pick a random
Direction and go right and that's what I
did and you can do that
but then there's a lot of stuff that you
won't unlock
until you actually start progressing the
main story so on my second playthrough
it's going so much faster because I'm
just I'm like I'm sticking to the main
story sticking to the main story
that's what you did Cloud raw
immediately explored same for Dustin
yeah I've heard of several people saying
that
no anime variety yeah we talked about
that in our combat I put that as one of
as one of the negatives is that it
needed more enemy variety
when do I think you should explore the
castle crowns and Highlands after doing
zenobi so Hogwarts I feel like you have
a little bit more room to explore that
one early but I I wouldn't explore much
of the Highlands until you get the broom
and I know some people like say they're
it's fun to like explore on foot and
stuff too
I I just the broom just opens things up
so much
but I mean again that's kind of the
beauty of it too right like who am I to
say maybe
maybe I shouldn't say
I still feel like you could say if
you're holding the two hand-holding in
the beginning as far as like tutorial
like I felt like replaying it especially
I really have noticed it even more but
again you're it's gonna feel like more
hand-holding on the replay because you
already know everything
oh hold on
we already talked about this but the
beginning
I would say I guess you would say the
prologue
the prologue was outstanding and what am
I including in the prologue um I'm
including like fig and ostrich Plus
grain gots
was so good
that was so good
when do I think
um
oh I already answered that okay
yeah Nick exactly that intro
that intro
I almost feel like that will will get
into like
oh man like I guess you would say like
that how it all fits together
oh dude hold on presentation
Music and Sound uh and I'm just gonna go
ahead and say 10 out of 10.
music is fantastic
the music is fantastic now I've seen
like some people that I I don't wanna
I'm not gonna call anybody out
some very supportive members of our
community I love you guys but I've seen
some comments in my YouTube videos some
people saying like there were there was
there was a member here who
they they watch our streams every now
and then they come in a lot of videos
I'm not gonna call you out by name don't
worry but they said that they were
that they like to turn off the the music
and play the music from the other game
the original games
I'm sorry what like yes that music is
phenomenal in the original games
Jeremy Soule did a great job yes but
dude this music is incredible incredible
and stands right up there with those
other games anyway I digress but I just
I I couldn't end this without
giving a shout out to the music because
the music is just
it's it's so good it's fantastic
Cloud rocket wait did you really say
that right
I promise I did not see your comment
before I started talking about music
oh that's so funny no no to answer your
question we had not touched on it yet
okay what am I forgetting anything else
guys on Main quests
I'm trying to make sure we hit all the
main
I mean I guess that would be it right
like the prologue at the beginning the
first trial second trial third trial the
final mission
you guys never really did say too
strongly about the lack of a True
Companion system
and I guess this is my review so I
should probably take it out because for
me personally it didn't bother me like
would have been cool if they accompanied
you more often
yeah I mean I think it could have added
to add it to it
but I'm not going to include that in my
list
because I just don't think it was too
big of an issue
there are already mods out there where
it's like they're adding people they're
they're letting you take companions
anywhere
all right two hand holding in the
beginning I'm trying to decide if I
wanna if I wanna stand by this one or
not because
in a way it is necessary
and I felt like they did try to break it
up a little bit by like okay
yes you've got to learn this stuff but
here you get to go to hogsby now at
least on this Quest so it's like they
start to give you a little bit
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say plus minus
on this one
because it's it's almost like a
necessary evil but maybe you could find
ways to streamline that a little bit
more in a sequel or anything you do in
the future
all right all right now we're getting
some people speaking out about the
companions I knew if I took it off you
guys would start
so Justin said it sucked especially when
they literally left voice lines in and
handed at a True Companion system
Alexis flown toward a sunrise with
background music playing oh I know it's
so good
that's a good point too Craig we'll talk
about that here when we get into more
Hogwarts and classes
it didn't bother me per se Cloud Roth
says but they were calling them
companions right right right see and and
they did join us on some missions
but I think early on people thought and
they may I mean to be fair they may have
even marketed it marketed in a way that
it seemed like
people were going to be able to like oh
like like the very beginning of the game
that's actually a good example when
Weasley is like hey you want to take
natsai or Sebastian to show you around
hogsmead
that's a good point they kind of set it
up
to where
it appeared that you were gonna have
that option like later in the game like
you've got to go and Tackle this really
tough dungeon this really tough area you
need to take someone with you to help
out
if he did a Nash Winder by myself
wish someone could have seen that uh
wish my friends were here
I've definitely heard the ashwinder one
I don't think I've heard the wish my
friends were here
with cross wands that's right Alexis you
do you get to choose nasai or Sebastian
there as well yep yep yep
all right so I'm it doesn't sound like
we're forgetting any other main quests
though
all right side quests cross wands
uh actually we're gonna say plus minus
because
super fun end it too soon
not repeatable
Chandler said he's he was going to watch
this tomorrow Chandler I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry
he's like oh my gosh retro you said in
depth I didn't know it was gonna be
two and a half hour stream
don't worry we're gonna put in we're
gonna put the time stamps we're gonna
break all this down I'm gonna be up till
who knows when putting time stamps in
oh goodness uh let's see Cloud Roth I
think took companions out because it
wouldn't work well with some of the
other missions way more work for
dialogue and then it could create
branching choices which they cut yeah I
wish there would have been more
branching stuff but I I get it
that's another good point Dustin yeah a
lot of hand holding because a lot of
people aren't Gamers Harry Potter fans
and want to make their own wizard
at least the lock picking game went down
to a button prompt on the easiest
difficulty did it really
yeah where did where do we talk about
that
all this stuff and we haven't really
talked about I mean I guess that's side
quests
oh no hold on that should be in
mechanics too
all right
alohomora minigame
I will say I was initially too hard on
it
it is not very difficult however I do
like many of the other Solutions I've
seen online better like maybe as you
upgrade alohomora
then you eventually get to a point where
you can unlock everything or
or you like you can unlock the one below
it
so then maybe by the end of the game you
still have to do it for level three
locks but level two and level one you
can unlock automatically yeah I mean I
haven't seen anybody who
I mean it's it's a mini game right it's
not
what is really the point of it I guess
like let's think about this from a
gameplay perspective it's almost like a
uh
kind of like a palette cleanser like
like if you've just been in the middle
of a heat of battle it gives you that
time to just kind of like like catch
your breath for a second
but a lot of it is just exploration
I guess they were looking for something
that would give you just a little bit of
bringing some gameplay to the alohomora
spell so it's not just
alohomora and that's that
which really I mean they kind of had to
invent this whole tiered system of
alohomora anyway
like Cloud Roth I like the mini game but
it's immersion breaking
Nico the house self Quest is top tier
wait house elf Quest
are you talking about the Slytherin one
or are you talking about the
witch household Quest
more things like crossed wands
yeah yeah yeah yeah the Imelda missions
so I'm gonna also say
on the side quest
um plus minus on
thank you
while the flight missions
I'll say that was cool like I like those
the time trials
that was fun
and any other thing that's not
repeatable
oh where are you going to the cave
looking for deke's friend yes yes yes
Tobbs quest with the acromantula there
yeah there were a lot of memorable
side quests a lot of memorable ones
treasure Vault side quests are too
tedious
um
maybe I could I could see that I could
see that in some instances
I think the biggest thing was The
Treasure of all is the rewards
I I think it's
which we've already talked about that a
little bit but just like treasure vault
lackluster Rewards
yeah haunted hogsmeade for sure which
that one's timed exclusive
haunted hogsmead
okay what do you guys think about
house exclusive missions
because I'm pretty sure a lot of us
asked for this actually I may have even
been one of them
I I may have even been one of them
because there's part of me that says
oh man there's part of me that says I
wish there had been more
but then that's like so much harder from
a development perspective and you can
even you can see so the jackdaw quest is
is really the one
where they tried this out
oh my gosh I just more stealth
oh this one might be controversial
so I'm including this as a negative
because I feel like they need to be more
more of them
I actually like the stealth stuff the
sneaking out at night
like they they teased it right with the
Sebastian Quest
um so let's say cons I'm gonna put that
as a separate one
although I don't know if this falls
under
wait actually we'll put that here
consequences
or sneaking out
oh this one's tough though man because
would you really would we really want
this
see this is a thing I feel like when
they're sitting there in the developer
room
that to us as fans sounds good
it sounds good on paper but it in the
actual gameplay
wouldn't it be annoying
like I feel like it's one of those
things that the first time you do it I
mean we could teleport anywhere right we
can use the flu Flames go anywhere we
want
in in this game like the way it's
structured
oh I'm hesitating on this one now you
guys
these are probably the conversations
they had like when they're developing
this
oh we'll come back to that
let me catch up with you guys
hufflepuff's exclusives is way better
slytherins sucks
so I I'll say this Nico hufflepuffs is
cool simply because of the location
but I think Gryffindor
as far as like just a pure Quest like
you take Azkaban out of it
I mean the character really doesn't even
do anything at Azkaban either you just
walk down a Long Hall
that's it as far as like a game like
gameplay like I think Gryffindor
probably had the best one I think the I
think the Gryffindor one was the longest
one too
why couldn't peeves interact with us on
a quest
the library sneak doesn't count should
have had more you think you think okay
Dustin says more house related quests
Moonlight Moon spark also says Morehouse
Quest
great Aurelius has more how specific
quests
I haven't seen anyone say no yet
but then wouldn't we just be sitting
here complaining like oh dude Ravenclaw
got the worst quiz right
how about this
how about this I do agree with you guys
on this point let's say
a I think there should have been a quest
line
for house
to where each house has one quest line
that is unique to that house
and let's just say it's like
four or five quests
or five missions I mean four or five
missions
instead of
like the jackdaw thing was cool I like
that they tried like that's an example
of I feel like they they took they took
a risk there and yeah we're gonna now
now we're gonna sit here and rate and
say well this one got a better one
because that's what we do right
but I like that they took a chance on
that I do so that's why I leave I leave
it as a plus because I think it was
great to take a chance on something like
that but then as far like I would have
loved to have seen a full-on
house quest line I think that would have
been cool
house exclusive Quest ad replayability
true
true lots of detention yeah there would
be Craig like if like if
if there were consequences for sneaking
out
sucked after replay getting out of your
common rooms just because you keep
getting caught I know right see that's
that's kind of why I took that one off
the list because I think
us as fans it's one of those ideas that
sounds great on paper but then when you
get in the right when you get actually
making the game
it's like oh dude they would hate this
they would hate this
all right
consequences for anything yeah we talked
about that a little bit already Cloud
Roth
um
did I not write it on here anywhere I
know we taught oh man I was taking I
didn't take hardly any notes up here
down here we started taking really good
notes but yeah we gave it like a six out
of ten as far as like this is where we
talked about it we talked about it with
the main story plot like ethical
morality choices
all of that but I agree it also impacts
the gameplay too in that
choices need to matter
yep
so I don't know if that goes under
consequences
maybe a presentation is kind of like our
our catch all down here
it's not really pre it's not really that
either though
maybe maybe it's more under under
mechanics
um choices
immorality
like a four out of ten
need more consequences
for actions
both both
I mean and you could do this in a way
like I know it's I know it's asking a
lot I know
but you can do this in a way where you
have like these big sort of tent pole
decisions to where you've got to make
make a choice and if you make this
Choice then it then things go down this
path but then that's just a lot more
stuff to design
as far as the gameplay goes
Dustin Chandler's gonna look back on
this spot and start crying
a lot of those scores on set well that
that's what I was saying at the
beginning like this is not
I'm not taking this is not like an act
we're not going to average out these
things you know
not gonna average them out
because there are certain things that
wait more than others
uh Moon spark the adding of stealth or
getting caught sneaking out at night is
like the alohomoral lock situation
um
so maybe more oh maybe if there were
more like stealth missions because I've
made this comment before
I love stealth in games
I do I I will try to go like for a full
pacifist run in games like I'm a huge
Dishonored fan
but in this game I didn't care about
Stealth at all a because the combat was
so fun
but I would I would have liked for a few
more stealth missions yeah
so I think
so that's why I'm going to leave this as
a negative and like I I personally would
have liked to have seen more stealth
sections some people may disagree with
that
all right so then there was one more
thing
um
oh summoner's Court
also I mean I kind of put this one in
the same categories cross once I thought
this was super fun
um it's not repeatable though and that's
my negative
I feel like it should have been
repeatable
and more
um
not repeatable and needed more
uh what do you call it just like
opponents
dreaming plays games a dreaming thank
you so much
for the membership there just woke up
had to catch my guy before he got off
stream loving the regular videos hey
appreciate it dude thanks for the
support glad you're enjoying them yeah
this has been a uh our full in-depth
review of Hogwarts Legacy we are getting
close to the end here
we're getting close now when I say in
depth I mean we we have went really
really in depth here really in depth
uh care says maybe no detentions but the
relationship with teachers goes down the
more you sneak out during curfew
oh yeah he'll know Cloud Roth I mean he
he even said at the beginning like don't
hold back and I'm gonna review it at the
end I'm gonna give my overall thoughts
at the end too which spoiler I love the
game absolutely love the game uh Dawes
welcome in speaking of sneaking
constantly let's not forget essentially
what you had to do in the PS2 version it
was it was more scripted that's true but
like any time it was night you're right
yeah as soon as it switched over tonight
everything was you did have to sneak
around yep good point
no greater release we got we got that
right here under uh under presentation
they need to add Red Dead Redemption
people's reactions to the thing you do
so people around feel more alive and
react to you
it is a little weird
that you can just cast spells like crazy
in the castle and just like nobody
reacts to anything
now how do you do that though how do you
[Music]
how do you do that I mean I it's almost
like do you want the professors to jump
out and say no you can't cast magic you
can't be doing this in the Halls
Five Points from Gryffindor right
that's another one of those tricky ones
where I feel like as a non-game
developer it's hard for me to say like I
will say I would like I I agree with you
though I agree with you
hey Justin with the five gifteds uh
Dustin thank you so much for gifting out
those five memberships guys if you just
got one of those make sure you think
Dustin for the gift and membership you
also have access to the emotes now on
our Channel
and he had a special role in the Discord
as well
I haven't seen Ellen Ellen was here at
the very beginning she was here very
very briefly at the beginning
and she usually is uh she's usually
always not too far lurking around
uh generally maybe an added game mode
where you can choose if you want to
sneak out
what do you what do you mean by add a
game add a game mode
all right I feel like obviously we
didn't touch on all of the side quests
and everything
oh we didn't give a score for this one
either
main quests I'll say seven out of ten
because what what's what's good was
really good
these were really good
second trial was a bit repetitive fourth
was way too late for the grab horn a
little bit too hand-holding in the
beginning
uh maybe maybe an oh maybe an eight I
keep wanting to go halfway on some of
these
I'll go eight I'll go eight there
actually
all right side quests
now because I hit it so so hard right
here on the gear loot I'm not gonna
consider that I'm not gonna take that
into account
on the side quests
so I think
oh man Merlin Merlin Merlin Merlin
you guys kept wanting to talk about
Merlin
foreign I'm going to say plus minus on
these two because
Merlin trials
enjoyable but not enough
variety
for the amount that they have in the
game
and then some of you were saying the
rewards I I agree the reward is not
I think it would have been awesome I
can't remember who suggested this but
they were saying imagine when you
complete all the Merlin trials you get
like a full Merlin set
that would have been epic
rewards meh
meh Rewards
for the Merlin trials I think I I
enjoyed them more than most people I
feel like
oh oh big big big positive
I'm putting this at the top
Infamous foes
I loved that I thought the infamous
photos were great
almost wish there had been more more um
now this is just me this is my personal
opinion right
this is my own personal review I know
other people there was a lot of people
were like oh man I don't want I hope
there's not too much combat in this game
I think there should have been more
combat
Centric quests
I do
and what I mean is like not necessarily
exactly like the infamous those but more
things where combat is a big Focus
and I know they have the battle arenas
but yeah like the combat is just so good
it's just so good
and you just you just never have a need
for all those amazing traits and all
those amazing unlocks that you get
Craig house points mean nothing
well they don't even really have it I
mean it's it's kind of like a story
thing right
zodiac welcome in how's it going
dreaming you think it's interesting they
have dialogue for other professors when
you cast dark magic around them using PC
mods oh I didn't know that
I didn't know that I mean that that's
probably just indicative of the fact
that
at some point maybe they did want to
have some kind of uh
morality thing going on
wish there was a system for uniforms
felt odd that our headmaster's so
straight no one seems to mind what we
wear
that's one where I'm kind of like okay
with them breaking the lore bit let us
wear what we want
because otherwise then the gear dude you
take away the Cosmetic options then gear
really doesn't matter if you have to
wear
anytime you're in the school if you have
to have all that on
welcome in Chris how's it going
should have been 90 Infamous foes battle
arenas need an infinite mode where you
go like high score Daw is 100 agree on
the combat combat is what got me truly
hyped for the game
especially because it feels like a a
true representation of how battle with
once would be yes because they nailed
that
something that no Potter game has ever
done they no Potter game has ever been
able to nail combat like they have here
yep long distance fencing indeed wanted
to wear what I wanted especially with
the RNG it could say yeah yeah yeah for
sure all right well obviously we can't
go through every single side quest I
mean that would take us all night so in
terms of review of us of the side quests
though man
I'll say nine out of ten here
and then a lot of these it's just like
suggestions for like future
and then here like I I enjoyed this
enjoyed this enjoyed this I just wanted
more of it Merlin trials
I could see why people think there are
too many but
if the loot if the uh not the loot if
the reward was better
then maybe people wouldn't care if there
if the reward was better and there was
more variety then it probably wouldn't
be as big of a deal
all right this is a big one
Hogwarts
and I'm gonna put classes in here
as a plus minus
and actually that one needs to go at the
top because that
actually no you know what hold on first
secrets
you know what plus plus
the secrets
here hold on hold on hold on
I'm just gonna I'm gonna list all these
separately secrets
attention to detail
respect for the lore
common rooms actually you know what
common rooms I'm gonna say plus minus
and here's why
common rooms
fantastic visually
but
really serve no purpose
but serve little gameplay purpose
I can't believe that they didn't do
something like the bulletin board from
the old games
that I thought that was like an
automatic maybe they just didn't want to
like copy that exactly
I can't believe we didn't have like
little meetings with friends in the in
the common room at night like
sneaking down and sitting by the fire
and having a little conversation and
hushed voices
they just they just weren't utilized
enough and they they put so much care
and time into them
and then I think the only other time you
you go to them is you know if you choose
to or after the the seasons as the
seasons change on my second playthrough
I just had the season change and I woke
up again in the common room
so fantastic visually as well as like
the respect for the lore
is amazing
where are my roommates yes Chris says I
wish the bulletin boards were the side
quests originated yeah they there needed
to be more
how do I word this it's like
student life is what I'm getting at
and we talked about this a little bit
earlier with with the NPCs
but it's like I feel like there's not
enough of this of the Student Life
aspect of this game Chris huff and puff
thank you so much for your four month
streak as a channel member here
thank you so much appreciate that Chris
happy to have you as a continued member
of our community here
okay going into the game I feel like a
big part of this one
classes in student life go hand in hand
a big part of this goes back to the
expectations
what were you expecting going in
if you thought this was going to be like
persona
like Bully
then you were probably disappointed with
how things played out
you were probably disappointed the way
that they chose to handle it is
everything sort of
filtered through the storyline
so all the classes were story based
and then the professors would kind of
call you back for some extra help but
basically you go to class once
maybe is there anywhere you go twice
I don't think there is
there might be one that I'm just
forgetting about but it's like the
classes were
so it's like they just don't they they
didn't have
much of the Student Life there at all
now if you've ever played a game like
persona
now clearly this was this was a design
choice
so I'm not saying they should have went
the full Persona route that's not what
I'm saying I'm just saying like edit in
its current state I felt like the
student life
that aspect of like getting to know the
classmates suffered a little bit because
of that now the reason I give it a plus
here is because when they do it
like the cutscene
and um the cutscenes for the classes
Plus
the little the little mini game that
usually follows
I'm just gonna say the cutscenes plus
activities
are well done
and like you see this with each class
you know in Hackett you have the duel
with Sebastian
uh herbology
she asked you to go and get the venomous
tentacula and you go with Leander so
that's like gives you that little chance
to kind of bond with Leander a bit
there's the one with with Ronin of
course they use that as an introduction
across wands with sharp that's where you
get introduced to Garrett Weasley and
you can go back into
private Sharps private study area
so it's like like when they did it
it was cool now could they have done a
cutscene
for like every single like that would
have been tough now you do that's right
you do go back and and it'll just do
like a quick like like a quick
abbreviated cut scene for the class
so again it was like it was a conscious
decision not to go like the Student Life
Sim route
Cloud Roth says it doesn't feel lived in
uh Dustin if they add Wizards chests
gobstones Etc they need to put them in
the common rooms
oh
Dustin that's such a good idea like the
common room should have been like your
little like it's like your Social Hub
you know
Social Hub
for many games
Cloud Roth I don't want persona but it
doesn't
but doesn't it feel like we're never in
class exactly yeah see that's where I'm
kind of like I want to be careful with
how much I'm being critical here because
I'm not saying that it should have went
the full Persona route I'm just I'm
talking about that as as like comparing
a game that does go the full
Student Life Sim route because clearly
they want to tell a story here and
that's
if you're doing that it's really it's
really hard to if you're gonna make it
more story based which man I mean
persona
they do it somehow but then they also
make like in other areas like it's it's
mostly turn-based combat so you're not
dealing with the same type of combat and
but yeah Persona is probably one of the
a good one to like compare and contrast
it with
you go twice for heckett Joseph said
with how big the castle is first years
would have to get buff really quick
twice yeah the second time exactly
Dustin that it's it's like the cut scene
personally uh Chris having puff person
was a tad disappointed with the
cutscenes love the game just hope the
classes be more Central yeah they
definitely the classes are pretty much
there for you to learn a spell
get to know the professor a little bit
get to know a classmate or two
and then maybe you go back another time
for a cutscene you do get to know the
professors a little bit more
and I like I don't like that's a tough a
tough balance it's a tough job right to
decide how they
so again I I think to kind of summarize
what my ultimate critique would be is
I don't think it needed to go like the
full Persona route of like a student
Sim where you go to class every day
but I do think there needed to be more
elements of like student life and more
stuff involving
where you do have more than just one
class
and they could I mean think about the
way Persona does it like Persona doesn't
have these full-on cutscenes it's like
it's mostly dialogue
mostly dialogue we need to go back for
these classes
and dude I can't you want to know what
something I couldn't I thought
they teased the owls I thought we were
actually going to get
to take
a little mock owl at the end and like
both like a written form and then also a
practical form that would have been so
awesome I don't know where that fits in
here but they teased it at the beginning
I'm like yes we're gonna actually take
our owls that's gonna be epic and then
the library you even have that little
quiz in the library if you go do that
side quest I was thinking this is
perfect this is kind of like to help
trainee help practice
help training you up
Pratt you're getting a little practice
for the owl and then all the little
stuff with the uh
the actual implementation
that would have been so cool because
they mentioned Weasley mentions owls so
early on and I was I just my jaw dropped
I thought no way they're actually doing
it they're doing owls
I think we get a cutscene Dustin where
they like show show students taking the
owls but I think that's it
yeah it's tough balance one interactive
class just wasn't your personal favorite
I get that yeah and I here's one thing I
was surprised about there was no
I thought the professors would like Call
On Us in class and we would have to
answer questions
it's like no answering questions in
class
I think that would have been cool
I might be wrong Dustin maybe it was
people studying but I'm almost positive
there's a brief moment
toward the end one of the ending
cutscenes where you can see them
Blue Moon said both classes and the owls
mentioned essentially a tease left you
wanna you're left wanting more right
right right
all right Hogwarts is such a big one I
feel like there's a lot more here and we
probably shouldn't cut it off yet but
we're about to hit three hour mark so we
gotta get to the last ones here room of
re oh wait hold on we gotta review
Hogwarts overall
oh
I'm gonna say eight out of ten
and I could see why some people would
say seven and some people who like just
enjoy exploring I could see them why
they would say a nine
um
and I will say this about the secrets
needs even more
I'm keeping it as a positive I'm not
putting a minus there because I love
what they've done but needs even and who
knows maybe there are more that we all
haven't found yet
that one with the the werewolf story is
so hard to find
and it's also it's like it's hidden
right there it's in plain sight I do
feel like the map
the mini map almost hurts the
exploration a bit there because you can
kind of it's like you almost see through
the wall oh there's something behind in
this area
Destiny give it a nine
uh just the name the only aspect you
didn't like was the grand staircase
exploring Secrets everything is in place
as far as the classes room yeah like the
design of everything
like I said the respect for lore
it's also good
I just don't feel like we can say
oh man
like if we weren't including the class
discussion in this I I would say
probably a 10 honestly
but by including that plus the plus the
common rooms
eight is probably eight maybe is eight
too harsh
Cloud Rost this first few days it was a
10 out of 10 now it's a seven or eight
I can see that
love the castle itself they did a
beautiful job 100 100 agree
100 agree
I'm gonna keep it at eight out of ten I
can see why
because I think and maybe that's because
I think they could you could do so much
more
foreign we even with as much as they did
right even with as much as they did like
if they were able to oh
if you're able to get and see a lot of
this also ties into the Hogwarts stuff
ties into the top where we talked about
Quest givers and
The Supporting Cast ties in with a lot
of those too
I'm teetering on the verge of bumping it
back up bumping it to a 10 or a nine
rather
oh I want to go 8-5 but I'm I'm sticking
to We're not gonna do half points
yeah I mean when we started this I said
seven is is good like if I give
something a seven that's good
so 8 out of ten is is even better it's
like even better than good
Blue Moon a Hogwarts 2 game would be
good in my book if they copy pasted the
castle and they're pretty much
okay
we're gonna have to do a whole another
episode a whole nother show on
DLC SQL talk for sure because that ties
into so many things I want to talk about
blue moon but I don't want to get I want
to I want to finish out we're so close
we're so close here
little quizzes related to class yeah
yeah exactly Northwoods and see that's
like you've got so many things from the
book lore that you could have pulled
from
almost like
like that quiz that you do in the
library like imagine if instead of
having that girl ask all those questions
imagine if they had like kind of pulled
that out a little bit and separated
those like maybe you get
two or three questions in ronan's class
you get two or three questions in
herbology class you get two or three and
then you can still go in the library and
take this big quiz and then you have an
owl at the end
oh that would have been so cool
all right room of requirement
oh man this one is a big one because
it's something we never expected I I
love the fact that there is something
there for people who don't
like like the whole base base slash
World building aspect of it
is super fun
customization
incredible
a negative
what's the point of it all
not not that everything I mean
I I played it many many hours into a
game like Animal Crossing and there's
not really much of a point to it you hit
a point in that game
where you're just chilling you're just
relaxing that's it's just therapeutic
so I feel like that's kind of what they
were going with there
but
it's it you hit again it this ties back
into my critique
with with the gear in the loot
like all these traits all of that stuff
that you can you can weave and create
from the Beast fur I better say this by
the way could you imagine if I closed
this out and we lost all the
oh at least it's in the live stream it's
recorded live we could go back and find
it
oh so maybe we should say plus minus on
that but it's just like all that stuff
you can use those resources for
there's not a lot of reason to do it
comes a puppy mill
oh man
way better than expected Dustin says
still too small both with the number of
beasts per varium space for potions and
stuff feels pretty cramped if you max
out your conjuration oh maybe I haven't
put stuff put enough in there because I
don't feel like mine feels cramped at
all
but again like I feel like I hit a point
where I've got everything I need I don't
need to be
constantly Brewing all this stuff
anymore
so let's just say
you Rewards
and utility
or maximizing
are lacking
I do wish I do agree with you I feel
like I don't know if they were just
limited by like what the constraints
were
but
need
space for more beasts
and more variety like why are you just
limited to four uh that there's got to
be a technical reason for that right
I can't imagine that that's they're just
like hey you can only have four species
in here just because
I think that's got to be a technical
thing
yours is cramped and cluttered right if
they have a nightmare job of trying to
have the professors call out each of our
assume Nate wait who did somebody say
they needed to call out our actual names
I don't think he'd have to call it names
I mean I think it's just like a
it's like a dialogue choice you know
they don't have to say your say your
actual name it just pops up as a just
like it normally does with the subtitles
and everything and then you just like
you choose your response
room of non-essential yeah yeah yeah
Alexis doing a playthrough right now I'm
only wearing original gear
and I don't think you're gonna have a
big problem I really don't I think
you're going to be able to make it
through the whole game fairly easily
even without putting on traits or
anything
so yeah I think the base World building
is great I just I haven't even had
enough time to really devote to this yet
but I've seen some incredible
Creations some of the stuff that people
have made already in here is insane
it's insane I love that you have the
customization options too
I mean like change the color you can
change the size of all these things
it really is awesome
I'm having a hard time deciding like how
you would score this though because it's
like it's just not something that I
personally
use that much
but I totally get why a lot of people
would enjoy it but like like from a
review perspective like from a critical
perspective
I mean I I feel like probably eight out
of ten nine out of ten
I did listen to uh nightly nerd fellow
Hogwarts Legacy Creator who was really
looking forward to this because he said
he loves
he loves like world like uh Base
building and stuff like that not when
did I say World building what the heck
Base building
but there was a critique he had what was
it he said about it
there was there was some critique he had
I guess that it's like there's just no
I almost wish there was some sort of and
it doesn't have to be a huge like reward
but but I feel like there needs to be a
sense of progression I guess
you know even with Animal Crossing you
do have at least some little rewards
along the way of like
you might in in Tom nook's shop one day
there might be some new piece of
furniture that you can get and you can
put in here but here like you unlock
everything and that's that's just it
there's also in Animal Crossing they
have like a rating system so you can you
can get like a five-star Island
based on like how stylish and how you
know how well kept and everything your
Island is
so I'm not like like when I say there
needs to be more
rewards I'm not saying it's like oh you
you unlocked
five new
spells or something I mean I'm not I'm
not saying like that
it could be it could be little like like
minor things as well
Nico says the base building feels
pointless at times if there's not much
you can do with it yeah yeah and that's
why I'm trying to like
like relate it back to a game like
Animal Crossing or stardew stardew
Valley like the I mean I think they
definitely took inspiration from these
games 2020
Animal Crossing those were some of the
First videos on this channel that
started doing really well for me or
animal crossing videos
and it was a time when people were stuck
inside and we just needed something to
kind of chill and and Vibe with and I
that's definitely what they were going
with
this game was online The Base building
aspect would be top tier ooh
that would certainly add a new element
to it oh my gosh imagine Nico if you
could like invite people over and you
can you can walk around and tour each
other's
vivarium
Deke thinks your rating is fine yeah d d
comes in like once a week to review your
room of requirement
Craig I did in my time playing The Sims
don't need to be an interior decorator
anymore
you can have things diagonal that is
nice
just the name says I think it does what
it seeks out to do well but I didn't
spend much time there either yeah that's
why I'm having a hard time reviewing it
I feel like eight out of ten is probably
pretty fair
okay presentation
we already said music sound 10 out of
10. graphics performance this one's also
kind of hard to review because it's like
it's based on your platform again as we
said at the top I played on PS5 digital
Deluxe the game ran almost at a rock
solid 60 FPS for me I played on
performance mode
so I didn't have any issues there
I mean I'm I'm leaning towards like
nine out of 10.
there are some there are certainly areas
that look better than others man if you
guys the such a small thing
but the art team at Avalanche
go and look at the different just I I
almost I might make a Youtube short on
this
if you just look at the animations and
the the spell effects for each spell
like glacias defendo flippindo like just
a little animation when they when they
send out it's so good
so good
I think the only point I'm docking is
because
there's still a lot of bugs and there
are some
I mean I've been hit by a pretty big one
with with the trophy situation
uh
and it's it's taking them
it's taking them a while and they're
they're trying to get another game out I
mean
I know they're they're working so hard
right now they're working so
ridiculously hard because they're trying
to get it out on last gen they had to
delay it and then they're trying to
squash all these bugs and the major
stuff that people are having they're
running into with quests
and I've heard that there's a lot of
folks on PC still having issues as well
so I get it
I do I get it
Blue Moon says room of requirement
potentially a 9 or 10 in isolation
purely due to the labor they put in the
details I think it feels underutilized
due to the general game mechanics Blue
Moon
foreign
you took the words right out of my mouth
that's what I was trying to say
I'm gonna read it again read it again I
just think it feels underutilized due to
the general game mechanics that don't
support it well
there you go
there you go Dustin agree with the nine
out of 10 on performance Chris Graphics
were so good people complain about the
glitches in my opinion the art and
gravity yeah the art oh my gosh the art
team and some of the some of the shots
I want to shake the hand of whoever did
like the spell
what do I even call it spell effects I
guess
oh I just like one day I just
I just stopped and noted I hadn't
noticed it before I had not noticed it
before also the basic cast I noticed
this one early early on if you're just
uh like in that little area where you're
with fig kind of in the rock cliff area
and you just like cast just do basic
cast like flying off into the distance
you'll see like this little like like
the air kind of warping around it like a
little little smoke around it
that stuff was so good
that was so good I almost want to put
like character creation
as part of the presentation as well and
I would say
somewhat Limited in the Character
Creator there were a lot of things that
they
they definitely went more on the side of
let's just do a few things really really
well and not give you
full control over the size and shape of
your nose and like how thin and wide the
mouth's gonna be and the ear like they
they clearly went with a simpler
approach which I'm one of those people
that almost always goes with like a
preset option anyway I may tweak tweak
the nose and eyes just ever so slightly
and then I'm done
so I'm not someone who cares about it
but it is kind of weird that there's no
like height or no body types
so you can't go with like a thinner or a
heavier wizard
Wizard or witch taller or shorter yeah
that's that was a little bit weird too
oh haptics on Dual sense that's a good
point too
yeah those are those are solid Craig
Dustin fortunate not to have many bugs
over 90 hours oh my goodness dust and
that's something else I should probably
put for this
um we have played I would say we have
played over 100 hours at this point
between
our playthroughs and live streams say
over 100 hours of gameplay
all right bringing it through here we
are at 3 hours and 15 minutes
replayability
now if you weren't here for the opening
replayability does not have to be high
for it to be a good game I I think you
can have a 10 out of 10 game with very
little replayability
like to me last of us is a 10 out of 10.
it's my favorite game of all time
replayability though
it's not that High I mean I I enjoy
replaying it occasionally
but it's not something that you can just
replay a lot so it's not like a game has
to have replayability
but
this is one that people really really
wanted to be replayable
this is one where people really wanted
to play this over and over and over
again
and
this gets back to the expectations thing
too I still think there's a lot of
people out there there's a lot of people
out there who wanted a student life Sim
and there's a lot of people out there
who wanted an MMO
and especially if you're in that ladder
category the replayability is I mean to
like let's be 100 clear here this game
gave me 80 hours
the the value on that alone
is like through the roof okay
let's be very clear about that
it gave me 80 hours of that last of us
my favorite game of all time didn't give
me half that did not give me half of
that
Elden ring
some people love doing the Elden ring
like New Game Plus like the multiple
runs
that is the area to me where I think
Hogwarts Legacy could have the most
to improve on this current game
and this is where we also kind of get
into like DLC talk here I feel like so I
would say replayability is like I don't
know six out of ten or something
and I feel like I enjoy replaying it
more than than most do
you guys said four or five Christy said
eight yeah see I feel like a lot of
people are going to be all over the
board on this one
foreign
so for me personally to give you guys a
tease of my I don't know if we'll do
this next week or not or if I make a
whole separate video on this
but I've been thinking about this a lot
like what I would like to see for DLC
and if they're probably already working
on DLC you know regardless of what
is said publicly and all that you would
think they at least have ideas I don't
mean they're like building it out or
maybe they are maybe they're not
so what I say has no it doesn't matter
right
so maybe I should almost put this in a
separate
this is kind of like overall
they have created
such an incredible world
like Hogwarts Plus
Scottish Highlands
Incredible World
with a lot of great systems backing it
up great gameplay systems
so I I mean if you go straight into
working on a sequel
for whoever said somebody in the chat
earlier said for the next game or
whatever I think they should take
Hogwarts exactly as is I agree with you
but
how do you pull that off
and what I mean by that is you think
about games where
if they're a sequel and I mean I I can't
think of it I can't think of any
what is what is a sequel do you guys
have any example of a sequel that takes
place
in the exact same
world and the exact same location
and does it well
like I mean that's the reason like you
look at Zelda Ocarina of Time
that's right that's why with Majora's
Mask if they they had invent these
totally new systems
um
like yeah Mr like Hyrule in general but
they it's Hyrule is different every time
I can't think of when he either Dustin
and that's like insane to me
there has to have been a game out there
right that that tries it
but it never hit me until I was talk I
was on with Luke Stevens before the game
came out and I was telling him I was
like oh yeah I think the game's set up
perfectly for sequel
you've got this is your five you're
gonna do your six your seven they've got
the trilogy ready to go
and Luke does a lot of like really
in-depth breakdowns on videos and he
made the point he's like well yeah
but what do you do with Hogwarts
what do you do with Hogwarts
think about this guys in your first
playthrough part of the of the joy of
this experience was all the stuff that
you got to do in Hogwarts finding all
the secrets all of the Field Guide pages
that was so ridiculously fun
I'm gonna like I feel like the uh
oh man I feel like like the little stuff
like that needs a place so like extras
so like
Field Guide pages
secrets
lore like all that stuff
10 out of 10.
Spider-Man miles from Alice I was dolls
I was I was thinking about Spider-Man
how does Spider-Man how does Miles
Morales handle it
you just you have different
because you have a lot of side quests
and stuff but it's it's different stuff
right you don't just do the same thing
Blue Moon Hogwarts is the Mainstay 100
yeah 100 agree with you there
it's a pretty unique case they can
change the students and treasures and
it'll feel fresh
oh but like if you're if you're getting
to the treasures
in Hogwarts in the exact same way
it will not feel fresh I would I would
argue
I would argue it wouldn't feel fresh
now the reason I'm saying all this the
reason I'm setting up for this is
because I totally agree with you guys
how important Hogwarts is like you you
can't
yeah
I know people want to see other schools
and they want to see them do different
stuff it trust me it will not do as well
not this soon not this soon maybe if you
make like a 10-year plan and like at
year 10 we're going to ilver morning
right now we're in year one with
Hogwarts Legacy
maybe that maybe I'm like being too um
conservative with that estimate
or to whatever you guys know what I mean
maybe that's too out there for that
estimate but I just
so here's why my idea
or DLC
I think in in Miles Morales may be a
good example is I think for this and
they can they can phrase it they can set
it up however they want you know Miles
Morales it was like is it a full-on new
game is it a sequel is it a DLC what is
it right
so Miles Morales for those of you don't
know it released cheaper it was cheaper
but they said it was like
it's like a sequel but it's a shorter
it's a shorter sequel
what's Jenny's Point here they need a
show about another school
oh if that oh yes yes yes Jenny what are
you doing here I didn't think you wanted
spoilers
oh my gosh Junior's like lurking
that's too funny good point though
too early for another school yeah yeah
yeah
so for me like for me sitting on the
sidelines
and this is not before like before the
game came out I said year six is uh
Hogwarts legacy two your seven is
Hogwarts like it's E3 that may very well
be the way that the game goes
but
what I would say is I think it would
almost be better if you made year six
a like massive expansion
to Hogwarts Legacy the current game that
we have
because they have built like what I was
saying right here they have built such a
good world the castle
the highlands all that stuff is great
and sounds like we're all agreeing on
that
we just think that there needs to be
for a sequel or DLC whatever there just
has to be more like different things to
do but you can't throw away all the good
work you've done with Hogwarts you just
can't do it now again this is where I
say I'm not a game developer that's like
they're way more creative than I ever am
at coming up with stuff like that that
could maybe then it justifies a full-on
sequel and who knows I mean these days
like what
what difference does it make whether
they call it an expansion or a SQL or
whatever all I'm saying is I feel like I
don't want them to go away for like four
or five years
I don't I don't want them to go away for
like four or five years I want them to
take this Foundation that they have here
and build upon it
because there are so many good things
here
that we have highlighted in this
dissertation of a Hogwarts Legacy review
oh my our term paper here that we've
been writing out
there's so many good things
that with a few tweaks with a few
additions with the improving of a few
things here and there you could take
what you have and that's what that's why
I say DLC because I'm like hey next year
take everything you've got right here
and let's just do your six let's do it
let's do your six you don't have to
worry about making all these new secrets
for Hogwarts because you you keep the
Hogwarts that we have now in the
Overworld and yeah you're gonna need to
come up with more more secrets and stuff
for that more stories you can you can
even keep a lot of the same characters
introduce new characters sure but I mean
you can only you only need to introduce
a handful of them you don't have to
introduce a crazy amount of new
characters because you already have so
many that we should already know
so they have such a good foundation here
I would hate to see them just
immediately say yep we're going away to
work on a sequel and we're gone for the
next four or five years
so my personal
10-year plan or
Avalanche software
as a fan standing on the sidelines what
I think would be epic amazing awesome
is if we get your six as a DLC
I mean dude they've got a potential here
oh I'm getting excited now I'm getting
excited guys we're three and a half
hours in we're gonna end this stream
with a bang because I'm getting I'm
getting excited I fully believe they
have such a unique opportunity here to
do something special
of not being a traditional single player
game that is just
you release your you release the game
you put out a DLC or two and then you're
gone and then you go to the sequel
maybe I'm crazy maybe I'm way off base
maybe I don't understand
finances and what
okay I mean I mean because WB is
definitely going to want a sequel as
they should maybe I don't understand all
that but I'm saying
what if they turn this into
[Music]
not live service because no everybody
hates that word but what if like
what if like in six months
or I don't know three months we get like
a little like a little mini DLC like
gobstones Wizards chess another couple
of side missions another couple of
Cosmetics maybe a new spell like a free
DLC free update as a thank you
maybe it's like a night a 20 DLC or
something
then a year from now a year and a half
from now we get the big expansion like
the blood and wine Witcher Witcher 3
blood and wine right
Hogwarts Legacy it's like year six
that's the big expansion
then
the next year we do it again we get
another little mini one get another
little mini one like six months out
more mini games
maybe something to do like in the summer
like maybe you do like an internship
at the ministry
okay maybe we're getting a little too
big with that one but you guys know what
I'm saying here you know there's so many
different locations that you could go to
you've already built part of Gringotts
let us go do something at grain gods for
like a fun little uh summer mission
then another year from there you do your
seven another big expansion maybe that's
like 40 50. whatever you want to do like
I just don't think you need to call it
Hogwarts legacy two
it's Hogwarts Legacy
year six Hogwarts like it's a year seven
then
after that
take your character that we've created
and that we've carried through years
five six and seven
and you go out into your Wizarding World
career
you go to work for the ministry as an
award
hey hey what do you think
what do you think guys
all right let me get caught up on
comments sorry I got I got out Jude
sometimes I'm just like I'm rolling man
I'm rolling
all right uh Blue Moon says Hogwarts
Legacy too the school Sim JP says rather
not have to wait for an Ivor morning
game a show would be great too wait what
do you mean you'd rather not have to
wait like you want you want an over
morning sooner
yeah it were more we haven't even seen
yet but I'm telling you guys right now
would it sell well yes would it sell
like Hogwarts Legacy
no no
I do not believe it would
uh has to be quidditch DLC
why have a full quidditch stadium in
Hogwarts and Sporting Good swords in
hogmead I'll say Draco I'm personally
not one who's like leading the charge
for quidditch as wanting it but boy did
they drop a lot of hints in this game
boy did they drop a lot of hints in this
game all right you know what before I
get caught up on chat let's go ahead and
wrap up this this review here we can use
we can time stamp this section right
here
all right so my overall
Hogwarts Legacy score
and I know we we kind of ran out of time
to include more here
I was on a special video that
I don't know when you guys will be
seeing this video actually I mean it
should be fairly I don't know I don't
know but there's another Hogwarts Legacy
Creator who's working on a big video who
is they've interviewed a lot of other
Hogwarts Legacy creators
and they asked me my review for the game
like if I had to put a number score on
it and I said nine five
I think I'm more now around like the
nine range
oh and you know what since yep that
makes it even easier for this review
because we said we're not going to do
half points so yep it's a 9 out of 10
for this review
it's not a 10 out of 10. but it is one
it is one of my favorite games of all
time
it's one of my favorite games of all
time and I am so
ridiculously thankful
to the people at Avalanche and the
people at WB who
took a chance
because let's be clear here man they
took a chance Avalanche by far the
biggest project they've ever done
by far the most ambitious project
they've ever done
on WB Side by far the most Wizarding
World
most ambitious Wizarding World project
they've ever done
they went above and beyond
they absolutely did and I'm I am so
so thankful that it was made I'm so
thankful to see both
the mainstream games media
for the most part give it a fair score
and I'm anxious to see so many of the
fans who are enjoying it as well you
know what I think the fans have been
harsher than
I did not see that one coming
I did not do do you go on the man I love
I love some of the folks at the Harry
Potter game celebrated dude but man you
go it's it's like miserable
everybody's miserable over there it's
like complaint complaint complaint oh my
gosh I can't believe they did I can't
believe they did a camp why didn't they
do this why didn't it
just the nature of Reddit I feel like
it's just the nature of Reddit
so yeah that's that's where I met man I
truly love the game
all like all these like you know you see
four out of ten in some of these areas
that's why I said it's we're not like
reviewing we're not like waiting all of
this on overall scale it's one of my
favorite games ever
Boom review section done Chandler if you
dude if you made it this far Channel
guys if you weren't here at the
beginning Chandler would stop by
Community manager said hello said he was
going to watch this tomorrow
Chandler my man uh
I don't know if you have three and a
half hours that you can set aside of
your work day but if you make it this
far
you've had my respect you have my
respect good sir
okay and you know what just so it's
easier for me to find I'm gonna go ahead
and switch back our camera view here
let's switch back our camera view
and let me catch up with what you guys
were saying now Mr cold Wii Sports has
the same areas like tennis and bowling
Chris we're totally getting another full
game after the sales money mate oh yeah
yeah I mean there's gonna be a lot more
but that's what I'm saying see I don't
think they have to jump right to a
sequel
like I think Avalanche could be
I feel like this could be their next
their 10-year plan could be centered
around Hogwarts Legacy as an IP
oh oh and just to throw another
curveball out there to you guys
so another curveball
we talk about making Hogwarts Legacy
feel fresh and feel new
what if they some of you already said
different time period that that's
certainly an option like
to be fair like that should 100 be on
the table we don't have to continue the
Journey of this character they could go
completely different time period they
could go even more back in time they
could go I mean heck go into the future
go far into the future where people
reference Harry Potter like Harry
Potter's already dead you know it's past
past the time of Harry Potter
you could do that
but
one of the other ideas I think you will
see from fans
I'm just throwing it out there I'm not
even saying I would want this
but what if
oh dude
what if they remade
the original games
not even not even remake
no wait how does it go remaster no not a
remaster like a full-on remake
like Avalanche software
Harry Potter and the Philosopher's Stone
Sorcerer's Stone for us U.S folks
Harry Potter and the Chamber see
man
right
you already have Hogwarts
now mechanically you'd have to change a
lot wouldn't you
you'd have to change a lot
because Harry can't come in as a first
year
doing all the crazy spells that we got
to do but just throwing that one out
there for you guys to discuss all right
Mr Cole just make a new game and call it
Harry Potter the Muggle Destroyer oh my
goodness
oh Jenny you came back just to see if I
were done now we're still going
we are still rolling JP had rad oh I
already read that one oh my gosh I'm way
behind uh doll said I think one way to
do it could be able to visit areas
outside the proximities of Hogwarts
exactly Diagon Alley Azkaban Ministry of
magic 100 percent
100 sequel deal whatever like whatever
however they want to do it those are for
sure some areas
the base is there definitely need to
keep at it
keep it at Hogwarts so they can expand
on other things than rebuilding Nick
Nick said that as long as they don't
turn this game into live service and
only oh my gosh yeah I know it does
don't don't just do that
could be six years easily for the
earliest Cloud Roth says uh just the
name said Yakuza always takes place
mainly in the same City District they
change small things from game to game oh
interesting okay
oh my gosh don't do that thing don't do
the thing
uh Blue Moon Hogwarts needs to be the
base foundation for sure new consoles PC
Focus we can have expanded map with the
ministry diet all blue moon that's
another good point how held back were
they
we'll never know right how held back
were they by the fact that it was also
on last gen
we will never know Jenny can't wait to
watch this whole thing oh my gosh Jenny
we went whoo
Lee went in depth
Northwoods year six and seven as dlc's
is my my thought they could do something
story wise that would eat us somewhere
new well not eliminate Hogwarts entirely
Deathly Hallows spending time away at
first right right right
got to get it working on last Shin true
Cloud Roth true
let us rot Gringotts uh Hogwarts Legacy
the unspeakables the Legacy franchise
hey they said it they said it Dustin
WB said it I'll play anything they put
out I ain't right Jenny yeah I mean
Avalanche is
what a great spot they're gonna be in
now
what a great spot and that that might be
the most exciting thing of all is
because of the fact that they have
proven themselves
and WB has already shown the willingness
to to like take a chance and let them do
this now that they've seen what they can
do
man they should be able to hire lots of
new people
they should be able to expand their
teams
to where you have like these like where
you have multiple like some teams are
working on the DLC and then all the
while like in the background you're also
working on that big SQL project like the
what's next
Destiny love it small then big DLC then
eventually adult Wizard game right
great Aurelius loves it too
or in-game yeah I mean I feel like
that's I feel like that's our end game
right
maybe that's not even an avalanche maybe
just like like all like in-game or
Wizarding World
I feel like that's the end game
and somebody's gonna do an MMO at some
point I don't know if I'll live to see
it because I can't I can't believe it's
taken this long to get a game like
Hogwarts Legacy but someone
is going to do a Wizarding World MMO at
some point I'm calling it
it will happen I don't know when but I
think it will
and then like there I want to be fair to
also the people that really want the
Student Life Sim
because I do still think there's a lot
of people out there that want
that want that from the attic if you
guys haven't checked out from the attic
from the attic did a great review on
this and he definitely wanted it to be
more of a school Sim
um and so what he argued in his video is
that it's very he felt like Hogwarts
Legacy was trying to like be in both
worlds of like you want to go on this
Wizarding power fantasy but also be a
student and his argument which I
I don't fully agree with the argument
but I thought he made the argument well
and I can understand where he's coming
from
he made the argument that they should
have either went with like okay you're
gonna go down this power fantasy as a
wizard but if you do that you just need
to be an adult you need to be an adult
wizard or you go the Student Life route
and I think he even said they should
have had unforgivables at all but yeah
really interesting review
really interesting review I thought it
was a well-made video gave me a lot to
think about
uh Nick said if they did that you could
already see some people complaining
about how they originally said no
microtransactions
oh those wouldn't be if for so my idea
wouldn't be micro transactions that
would be like a story a story DLC
I mean I think when people think of
micro transactions it's like 99 Cents
for
this pufflepuff scarf not hey here's a
new story and we're putting a new spell
and we're putting a new uh quest in here
and we're putting yeah there's there's
cosmetics in here
I don't know I mean does that
what do you guys think is that what
people think when they think of a
that is an interesting point though
but yeah I mean I don't think I don't
think people would I don't associate
micro transaction with like a new story
DLC that's been added
but you're right people probably would
Nico Trilogy wise be cool if Hogwarts
like C2 cover to your six and seven and
the third game is
so try to do two years in one game
Cloud Roth I don't think they'll go that
in depth I want it I want choices and I
want choices that care from game
I agree with you Cloud Roth I would have
loved to have seen it I think at this
point they've already set themselves up
where they CA it would be hard to do
because there were so few choices that
matter
you would just have to go with a Canon
ending
and I think the Canon ending is the evil
one
I think it's the evil one for both
Sebastian I guess it's debatable which
one is evil on that
but I think the one that keeps Sebastian
at school
I think is probably the true ending that
they wanted you for
and then I think
the the keeping the power for yourself
is probably the true in it but again
that's I mean you cross that bridge when
you come to it maybe they just say no
you know what
we hear you guys who want to do more of
a choice so we're gonna have to jump to
a different time period that's an option
too
but I agree with you from the beginning
I would have loved the Mass Effect style
like you carry this character you're
going on a Trilogy now see they couldn't
they couldn't afford to do that because
when they're in early development they
didn't know
they didn't know how it was gonna pan
out
they definitely hit a home run and
there's Pro this project and their
biggest yet
Dustin agree nine out of ten for you as
well
uh Cloud Roth wasn't Harry Potter
related wouldn't like it nearly as much
as a standalone new IP
what do you mean if oh like if it was
wasn't Wizarding World
well then I feel like that would strip
away so much of what it is too
because I mean so I mean everything
about this game is Wizarding World down
to the mechanics because of how much
they showed respect to the lore right
is miserable in general
oh yeah and I did I saw the Yakuza
comment too
I think it's fair to have critiques and
acknowledge reality it's not fair to
focus just on the flaws oh yeah for sure
Chandler will have time
Founders era or into the future yes
Hogwarts Legacy 27
. oh my gosh like just try to imagine
like
Hogwarts Legacy Hogwarts with futuristic
technology
Hogwarts Legacy zombie apocalypse
oh you guys said you saying no on the
remaking the Potter games idea
foreign
Studio maybe yeah yeah
but I wish if they did that though you
got it you'd have to have them work
closely with Avalanche man
because this like this Hogwarts is the
video game Hogwarts as far as I'm
concerned from here on out like this
that is Hogwarts you know
so if you have a new studio do another
any game set in The Wizarding World
whether it's Harry Potter whether it's
in the future in the past like
bro you gotta get with Avalanche and get
get the castle okay
you got you all have to work that out
somehow
oh my gosh why did the Stream
there it goes there it goes all right
we're back we're back on track now
Retro's wife how was the stream it was
great created
yeah we sat we created a 10-year
business plan for Avalanche
they're good now
they're good to go
attend the same time as Merlin
I think one of the reasons they stayed
away from Merlin I haven't had a chance
to talk to James about this yet
I think one of the reasons they stayed
away from Merlin more in the story is
because it Merlin gets really
complicated in The Wizarding World
because
he didn't live
he would had to have lived in a
different time period than he was said
to have lived for like Arthurian
lore and all that
the timelines just don't
add up
at least that's what I've heard I've
never like really looked into it to know
for sure because he was said to have
went to the school right and yet he
should have lived
I'm pretty sure he should have lived
before the founders
if I remember that I could be wrong I
could be wrong
Side Story DLC as someone else uh
interesting idea JP raven fire
interesting idea
insane how much last gen has been
holding oh yeah in terms of like
technology and stuff
I mean hindsight's obviously 20 20 right
but
they're probably
they're probably wondering now if they
should have even if they should have
pulled the plug on it before I mean I'm
glad they didn't because I know there's
a lot of you in the audience
probably not people watching now because
they don't want to be spoiled but I know
there's a lot of people waiting on it
for last gen so I mean I'm glad they'll
get have a chance but think about it
when they made that decision ps5s and
Xboxes were still so hard to find
and now they're just they're just not
anymore
plus it's clearly I mean I'm not gonna
say it's like a huge problem for them
because I have no idea but I mean
clearly they're having some issues
getting it out
for last gen
uh just the name I feel like the only
thing that made me happy is definitely
adopting the original story in this new
style
Call of Duty what no way
no no I don't think they would ever be
able to like
do a game every year
with a a hog warp mod think we'll see
fans turning into an MMO fairly soon
yeah I've been I've been reading some of
the MMO or the uh
the mod stuff it's pretty crazy
pretty crazy
Todd yo Todd what is up dude
ladies and gentlemen say hello to Todd
member of avalanche software in the
house we just want to get the old gen
consoles out first before even thinking
about what is next yes Todd yes
Todd thank you so much for stopping by
dude
and appreciate all the hard work you
guys put into the game
amazing amazing stuff we just we just
had like a a three oh my gosh guys we're
almost at four hours
I can't believe we went for well we
haven't won fours yet but
yeah and we and Todd I will say I I see
you you know from YouTube comment I mean
I see a lot of YouTube comments of
people who are
who are eagerly awaiting it so people
are definitely still looking forward to
it
definitely still looking forward to it
uh Humboldt gamer was waiting on the
game
that was no nothing Beyond Good and Evil
2.
JP you're wait wait wait wait JP you
haven't played
you just watched this whole spoiler and
you didn't
maybe you just jumped in toward the end
because we were like spoiling everything
tonight
hey from the attic uh dude were your
ears burning we just mentioned you man
we were just talking guys from the attic
fellow Hogwarts Legacy well you create
content on a lot of different games but
you were one of the First videos I Ever
Saw making content on High Roads Legacy
we were just talking about
your recent video about
um
I thought that like I didn't agree with
everything but I thought you did such a
good job of putting that argument
together of like Student Life Sim wizard
power fantasy and like what the balance
of that is and if they should have went
yeah I thought that was great man
just randomly dropping in to say the
sequel should focus on Hogwarts its
surroundings ditch the massive open
world take inspiration of Olympus oh
yeah yeah we talked about see I don't
agree I don't agree but I get I get why
you make the argument I love the open
World stuff I love I love being able to
go and explore but like I hear your
argument of like that
that did at least in this game kind of
detract from the more Student Life side
of it
but yeah man if you get a chance I mean
I feel bad telling anybody to go back
and watch a four-hour live stream
but if you get a chance man go back and
skim through some of the stream hold on
let me just let me let me show you this
real quick
from the attic here's what we uh
we we had to pull out the notepad here
we had to pull out the notepad when I
said in-depth review I was not
I was not kidding and these were very
very abbreviated notes right here
very abbreviated
some consider the dark arts battle arena
micro Transit what no way
microtransaction like a dollar for cool
yeah yeah like if if they sort of be
like five dollars for a pack of 10
cosmetic items
the old gin needs to be done and fleshed
out where he probably first performed
yeah yeah for sure
Cloud Roth will always win more yeah
exactly right
but they want more too
that was one of the uh the blog posts
one of the first big interviews that
Alan two did
how are you you talked about that they
with support they want to do more
here we are supporting
and ladies and gentlemen Cloud Roth
gifting out the five tier one
memberships
Cloud Roth thank you so much my friend
for gifting out those memberships
appreciate all your support
oh dude I need to change the position of
them now I used I had them over here
because
they were kind of out of the way right
there but
I don't know now we need him somewhere
else
thanks so much Cloud Roth always
appreciate your support and guys if you
just got one of those make sure you
think cloud Roth
and also
how are you enjoy the emotes you also
get a special Discord role as well
discount on merch you do have official
merch if you guys want to check any of
that out
[Music]
oh no I'm way behind again
I'm way behind
twenty dollars for some outfits weapons
and amount like Assassin's Creed ancient
magic transports our main character to
another time cybertech upgrades oh you
guys we were talking about in the future
remake quidditch World Cup oh no I don't
want Avalanche doing that
no no no
no no no somebody else can do that
Avalanche no they're doing too good on
this I don't
don't remake which World Cup
Harry Potter magic awaken right if that
ever will that ever come out
James got us all in the Merlin hype
train it took off
he just yeah he made his main character
uh a descendant of Merlin
DLC is Sebastian
I don't know if that's gonna work for me
Nico considering uh the choice I made on
our buddy Seb at the end
because nah man we had I had to
that that boy needed to pay
that boy needed to pay
DLC is ominous
now that would be interesting
oh man has a video game
I'm like so intrigued by that now a
video game as like where you where the a
blind character is the main character
because it's such a unique way that he
navigates the world
DLC is okay you follow the story of how
Ann got cursed oh interesting
look at you guys now see you guys are
now getting excited too we're about to
we're about to push this into a five
hour stream no I'm kidding four hours
hard stop you guys harsh hot we're at
three 353 right now
Hogwarts Legacy but it's ominous uh
you're basically a daredevil wizard
Daredevil yes
sir there you go a game where the main
character is someone who's blind
the burning Shores DLC will only be
coming out for PS5
oh Horizon I was like wait Bernie did
they just announce I missed it
is it really and the main game came out
for PS4 too
I'm having uh having fun playing on PS4
I think Todd dude that's awesome to hear
man
thank you for letting letting the folks
know too we have we probably don't have
as many of them watching right now
because there were some here when we
first started our stream who mentioned
they were they were still waiting but
then when we said we're moving into
spoilery stuff I think some of them left
but we we did we did have some here
early on so they will be
delighted to hear that
and let's see what is it March 14th now
so just a little just a little under two
months
I mean hey right the the delay for for
next-gen it obviously
it obviously panned out obviously worked
out
oh oh Elle went to it
Elwood's getting to the investigation
find Benjamin B bring him back here so
we can question him
still have not gotten confirmation about
the game he worked on
oh my goodness the infamous minigame
the infamous minigame that we will never
know
just the name from the trailers thought
it was going to be about Merlin and
Morgana and their descendants in the
present dead wrong
gnome toss right I think it was meant to
be Dome toss I do
oh you're a ma JP
HL wait what is hlcc
awkward so I can see CC I already know
the story
yeah no problem from the attic it was a
great video it was it was a great video
Dustin ever since retro became full-time
he does seven hour less hey that's right
four hour talk streams
that's why we had to do this man
that's why we had to do it
I'm just now catching up to the point
where we had the gifteds okay I'm almost
caught up
micro transaction would be if we charge
speed up timers on plants and Potions
yes right yes that that is also how I
would Define a micro transaction
timers are pretty quick as is aren't
they they're pretty quick for certain
Potions there are some things where you
actually do I think there's some that
are up upwards around like 20 minutes
where you have to like leave
some of the bigger potions but honestly
you get to a point man where you can
spec out your remove requirement and you
just have so much going
and really I mean the way they designed
it
you should have there are certain things
that just like the wig and well they
don't want you to have to wait for the
Wigan world so the Wigan will that's the
healing that takes I don't know like 10
10 seconds or something I think
EA Sports quidditch right right
dlc7
escape from Azkaban oh my gosh
five hour stream no no no
no no no we might do a uh
I might I'm gonna I need to stream on
Twitch tomorrow during the day so you
can't go we can't go five but this has
been an awesome stream man I have loved
this
I'm gonna have to do this with future
with other games we play now maybe I'll
take all of this that we did all of my
notes Here
all the notes that we saved in our
notepad and then like make a video out
of it like a full in-depth review this
certainly helped me collect my thoughts
and like listening to you guys and your
feedback that was great
all this beautiful work done by
Avalanche and the port key the scenery
game could easily easily be used as CGI
for any Wizarding World but yeah they
it's it's
such a glorious
a glorious world
oh content creator
when I see this
oh another Highway sexy content creator
I got you that's right for uh I think
for um
don't you do a lot with Lynette on that
stream
Iz sub still haven't played the game yet
I thought it was cool that they added
the new house
new house what
what a new house
Wigan world is 15 seconds okay yeah I
knew it was pretty quick
underwater DLC oh
hey I'm actually caught up now look at
that
look at that we caught up
yeah we kind of got they kind of got a
tease on the underwater stuff didn't we
there was a little bit of it
DLC where morganock was actually alive
and wanted the power that she left
behind
wait we never do we ever see how oh
we never see what morganock
did we see what happened to her
and one thing I totally did not pick up
on people say that ran rock is still
moving in the final cut scene or the
last time you see ranrock they say he's
still moving I didn't see that
but I've seen enough people say it that
I believe them he so he was still moving
I mean I took it as the game I took it
as he was he was gone like he made they
didn't say they took him to Azkaban or
anything but I I took it as he like that
that threat had been
addressed
you saw someone get sorted for Azkaban
oh no no not sorted for Azkaban no if he
did that was like a mod or something
somebody messing around with a mod there
are house specific quests and one of the
houses goes to Azkaban in their Quest
Iz that might be what you're you're
thinking about
spam the chat with questions nah nah we
just hit four hours ladies and gentlemen
we just hit four hours they tease you so
hard with morganot thinking she was
really Morgan Lafayette I mean
I mean maybe
oh man all right you guys that was
awesome I hope I hope you all got had as
much fun fun out of that as I did I
don't know that anyone will ever
watch a four hour review technically it
wasn't a full four hours for the review
we had to ten minute countdown you know
then we chat for a little bit at the
beginning but that was a good
that was like a solid two and a half
hours purely of
us breaking down Story character
gameplay of Hogwarts Legacy
Todd member of the dev team at Avalanche
stopped by and said hello Chandler Wood
Community manager stopped by here at the
beginning and said hello
thank you guys so much for stopping by
and for all that you've done to uh
to make this world come to life man it's
been amazing it's been amazing guys I
didn't see anyone type this like the
whole stream
exclamation point giveaway I feel like
you guys you guys don't want to talk
about the giveaway because you don't you
don't want more people entering which I
get you want to increase your chances of
winning but I gotta be fair man I gotta
make sure everybody knows we are doing a
giveaway here
four
this right here
us version of the collector's edition
Hogwarts Legacy ancient magic wand
Kelpie robe
steel book
dark arts pack
regular the regular game box is included
as well
all here all here
Chris that you should enter seriously
guys some people like mods
I want all all the mods if you don't
have I know some of the mods already
have a collector's edition if you don't
have anyone to enter
for real enter don't just because you're
a moderator or just because you've been
around a while or something like I want
honestly like
I could probably say this
to the live streamers because I know you
guys are like the hardcore ones here I
mean I'd rather one of you guys win it
I'd rather one of our the people that
watch the live streams win it you know
nada I mean I'll be happy for whoever
wins but you know it'd be awesome if it
was if it was a long time supporter it
would
Todd probably has one already right
been wanting the one in the book so
badly
you would give it away Cloud Roth oh
Ellen if you win please send it to Todd
you don't have one Todd oh my goodness I
just now saw the comment back from Todd
oh my goodness
I can't believe so Todd my story is on
on the uh the day that the pre-orders
went up
I somehow got an order in on GameStop
James expect to go was live streaming
his chat was telling him when Gamestop
went up and he couldn't get one in I
don't know why mine went through but it
but it did it went through
so that is the one that I got from
Gamestop right there but then uh WB
actually sent me a uh sent me another
one which it's sitting over there right
now I have it I wish it could fit back
here it's just a little bit too big I do
have the steel book right there though
you guys can see that's the steel book
it's kind of hard to tell what it is
with the
PlayStation lights right there
but yeah so I'm not allowed to give the
WB one away but the one I paid for I was
like well I'd prefer to give this one
away give this one away to the fans so
yeah Todd dude feel free make sure you
enter that'd be awesome if Todd won L1
says if she wins to give it to Todd
you don't think that would be fair
Dustin if I won I'd give it to Elwyn
who'd give it to Todd Todd would give it
to Cloud
oh I know Todd yeah dude I was so uh I
was very
first of all very appreciative and
thankful that WB thought thought enough
of us to uh to send us one that was that
was very very kind of them but yeah that
I even got a pre-order in what dude what
Todd what I haven't been able to get
that I really want to get my hands on
controller
PS5 controller
I have my regular my regular black one
here
now that one
it was my final day at my old job and
they were having like a little goodbye
thing for me
all right last story last story and then
we're out we're out
they were having a little goodbye thing
for me and the pre-orders for that were
going up at I think it was like noon my
time or something maybe one Eastern or
something my time
and I was like oh my gosh
I gotta I I have to go to the bathroom I
have to slip away to the bathroom or
something in the middle of this and
that's what I did
slipped way to the bathroom
lock the door get on my phone
and I'm like okay I'm in there I'm in
there I'm refreshing the page
I'm on the PlayStation site I see it
I see the controller there
and I'd already do it I I'm experiencing
this stuff I logged in I had my payment
information ready to rock and roll
everything was ready to go and I could
not get it to add to my cart
I couldn't get it to add to my cart
and so I've been checking that
PlayStation website every day I'm like
come on guys order more of these make
more of these
I wouldn't even use it man I would want
to put it like
I don't know I would have it on one of
these shelves they make these really
nice
controller stands where you can like
you can like prop them up
Retro's Whispering inspire me I made it
Blue Moon enter it and
if you win you'll give it to Mrs
raconteur oh
oh that's right Christy got the
controller
Christy got an order in on the
JP just wants the Kelpie robe code
Christy will trade you controller for
collect
giveaways canceled guys
sorry
I'm kidding I'm not gonna do that but
Christy if you win I don't know I don't
know nah no I'm kidding no I'm so happy
Christy got one
James didn't get one either that that
went
that went even faster than the
collector's edition dude the wizard
Harry you're a wizard Harry
my goodness that scared me we haven't
heard Hagrid much this stream
Bryant thank you for subscribing to the
channel
wait Craig you got one too
you might have an extra oh my gosh Todd
dude if you had an extra
uh if you have Twitter Todd at retro
record tour
that would be amazing
now see I reached out to the WB the the
same contact I have at WB who hooked me
up with the controller or hooked me up
with the collection Edition I reached
out and said hey any chance we could get
a controller
I mean I was ready to pay for it I
wanted to pay for it but um they said no
that it was like through a different
company so I thought maybe Sony so I I
actually went and got
I found some Sony PR contacts reached
out to them and they said no it wasn't
through them either
so I'm like who has these controllers
oh it was never for sale in Canada Jenny
that's unfortunate
oh Christy just made a deal with elwin
look at that
I did look at Alexis
I did glance at the eBay prices I was
like come on guys
you got lucky on getting one they did
Todd they sold out so quick
it was crazy
still wishfully wanting how specific
controllers maybe one day
that's like such a tough thing because
you don't know how many to make you know
what you know what how specific controls
would be great for
is like a made to order
like where you go on the website and you
just order it
because it's hard for them to do stuff
like that not knowing because you never
know which one's gonna sell the most
right
I mean we know gryffindors can we know
Griffin doors gonna sell the most guy I
actually I don't know man I don't know
I don't know
yeah I did see that James and him are uh
freaking nerds they're giving away
another one
yeah so the giveaway the link for my
giveaway is The Gleam link yep The Gleam
link
all right guys this has been epic this
has been awesome thank you all for being
here so much uh anybody on the replay
Squad that goes back and watches this I
hope you all enjoyed it let me know what
you think in the comments below about
your full take on Hogwarts Legacy I
expect a full like you know multiple
paragraphs like we did I'm kidding I'm
kidding let me know what you guys think
too uh and for those of you who watch
this hopefully months later after you've
played it on PS4 Xbox One
let me know what you guys think man uh
and
what else do we have going on
we're streaming over on Twitch if you
guys aren't following us there check us
out on Twitch as well if you don't mind
spoilers we posted a video today this is
one of my
it's I worked really hard on this video
you guys could tell because it's going
to be it's a completely different
editing style it's a full sort of
in-depth breakdown of Sebastian and that
whole quest line
so check it out man let me know what you
guys think in the comments of that one
too make sure to give it a thumbs up
as always
thank you all so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon
later guys
as my voice just died out
okay I exaggerated a bit there but it
did kind of break right there at the end
when ladies and gentlemen four hours
will do that to you
foreign